good morning everyone
it being 901 and we're going to go ahead
and start the committee hearings for
today i would ask everyone to join me
and representative marston the saluting
the flag please
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
on the nation of god under god
indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
[Music]
and i'm going to open the public hearing
on hp 1246 fn
do we have
somebody uh introducing the bill for
representative cagney
well
if you don't mind
i don't even know
i have two
both in support
thank you mr chairman and fine
committee members
i am representative john burt i
represent goffstown ware and deerin and
i am opening or introducing house bill
and if you could hold any questions
for hopefully the prime sponsor or
anybody else wants to testify
thank you thank you representative
the committee calls carl huddleston new
hampshire state police
good morning mr chairman
good morning members of the committee uh
thank you for hearing from me
um i represent the new hampshire state
police and it was because of uh usually
when something comes before you
uh for a change in law it's because
something happened and that's correct
i happened to be
working
on the road one day with a couple other
troopers and
we had a driver from
vermont driving a commercial motor
vehicle who had a restriction on his
license from the state of vermont
for our ignition interlock device
however the commercial vehicle he was
operating did not have one
and
going through what the current law was
both state law and federal motor carrier
regulation
the only thing that we could
actually cite this guy for was for
disobeying the terms of his license
restrictions on another state which
obviously is an issue
so
this will
sure up
um
the law so that it applies equally to
everybody
and
will give us another tool in our toolbox
when it comes to
commercial motor vehicle drivers that
are
required to have an interlock device
representative testament
thank you thank you for taking this
question
uh
in a case like that where you find
somebody with a license that is noted to
be interlocked required or however
do you
then notify eventually through paperwork
the state from which they came
yes as a matter of fact we did we were
able to get a hold of vermont
once
the individual was convicted that
information went to vermont they did
take action further action against him
um on his license but yes
we had a conversation roadside with one
of the dmv
directors over in vermont trying to work
through this problem however
that was the only thing that we could do
with the time so this this will um
help that along
representative burr
thank you mr chairman and thank you
for your testimony
how many cases
of this
where somebody has a dwi in any state
for a motor vehicle but then their cdl
you know they're driving a cdl vehicle
how many
cases where the person was
under the influence driving a cdl
that i don't have the data on that i'm
sorry
thank you mr chairman um because where
i'm going with this is you know yes
his
license was suspended or
uh for his
vehicle but this is a federal
you know cdl is federal
so how can we
you know make this law that's going you
know to a federal
license
so um
obviously
this will be a disqualifying
disqualifies the driver from operating
and
there is both state and federal
regulation obviously that prohibit
somebody from driving
while they're disqualified
so we would cite them under the state
law however it also
at the same time is
federally noted goes under the federal
database uh said this database
so that
um even if somebody from another state
runs this particular individual's
driving license
one they can see the restriction on it
and two
as far as driving a commercial vehicle
if they have been stopped and inspected
anytime prior within the
first within the last 10 years we're
able to get that information roadside as
well so we can see their whole
history whether it be
state violation alone or
federal violations um
we have access to that so we would be
able to better
identify anybody that's that's driving a
violation of this or for any um
violation for that matter
in one last follow-up mr chairman uh
thank you
uh
well i guess
you know that answered it some but you
know i go back to that this is a federal
license
controlled by the feds
so why are we making laws
in conjunction
you know you know do we have the
authority i guess is the real question
yes yes we do so
um
the the feds
federal government
federal motor carrier
if you're
it's based on your home state's license
so for example the example i gave you
vermont was the one that
initiated the action against this driver
for an
ignition interlock because of a dwi
conviction
that information is shared
with the feds
they then
put in their database that this guy is
disqualified for these whatever the
reasons are
and
there is a federal
federal
regulation violation for
driving and
and via in
violation of the restrictions that your
home state put on your license but
um
the federal side of this will only take
action once there's action taken by your
license
home state i guess is the best way to
put it what are wherever you're licensed
out of
um
that state needs to take the action
against you before the
um federal side of this will kick in
so
state violation
issued by the state
once a conviction is
made or once the person has been kicked
convicted of it that goes into the
federal database
that's when it becomes available to
all everybody
and at that point
if somebody was caught in violation like
this particular driver was
there's a federal violation as well as a
state violation so this is the state
violation here that we're talking about
once that action is
has gone through the
court hearing
process they're convicted it then hits
the register
on on the federal side hope that answers
your question thank you
actually i just have a
if you could clarify um for the members
there's no um
there's no federal d.o.t police out
there that are doing it it's up to the
states to is could you explain that just
a little bit so the members understand
that it works um
so as far as as the federal regulations
go there are a set of federal
regulations
for commercial vehicle operation
and
there as the chairman just said there is
no
federal police if you were
that go out and force this there are
members in every state and territory
that have people that have been trained
and certified to enforce these federal
motor carrier regulations so we're
here in the state of new hampshire it's
the new hampshire state police
troop g to be exact and there's 35
members that are proper that are um
trained and certified by the federal
government to go out and conduct
commercial motor vehicle and
enforcement um
so no federal
police
if you want to call it that it's all up
to the states and the territories to to
enforce it
thank you for that clarification uh
representative true please thank you mr
chair thank you
if
i i thought the uh when you had a cdl
you know the state license was tied to
the cdo
if you lose if you lose your state
license
or whatever please you don't lose your
cdl you do and that's something that
was
cleared up a number of years ago so
yes your cdl is issued by your state
and
if you if
if your home state takes action against
you
um
it's directly
it's almost immediate whatever the
action is if you get it for example if
you get a ticket in california
eventually that information will make it
back to new hampshire it will go on your
driver's license so yes any anything any
violation or any citation or any
conviction
eventually will show up on your license
however
if it's from an outside state sometimes
it does take longer for that to happen
if that makes sense to you
follow
so so in up case when in the march
the uh the operator
would require that interlock device that
doesn't
that doesn't carry over to you
it does the issue that we that came up
was that
[Music]
we had no state law
that
allowed us to take
an appropriate action against this
individual we had to cite them for
disobeying the terms of their
restrictions on the license which is a
62 ticket here in new hampshire
this
would allow us to charge this individual
with
the actual
violation of not having the interlock
device installed on the vehicle he was
driving which is a far more serious
offense which carries a
far more significant penalty
so if i could clarify
similar situation would be if i was
driving
if i had a vermont license that said
corrective lenses and i was driving in
new hampshire without my corrective
lenses you would be able to cite me for
driving outside the restrictions of my
license but
not in this case the more serious
offense of not having the interlock that
that's correct and we've had two
instances that i know of in the last
three years where we've stopped
a commercial vehicle
and an interlock device was required
but was not installed so this
it's not just one insulated ice incident
this is the one that drove us to be here
today
but there have been other instances of
this happening and again it's not
a common occurrence however it is a
significant
offense it's a serious offense
and
we need the ability to cite the
individual for
the serious events and basically we
would be citing them and they would be
subject to the same penalties here in
new hampshire as if in this instance the
gentleman from vermont so it's
letting us enforce the
the same law the same way
so in other words you would be treating
any out-of-state driver the same way
you'd be treating a new hampshire driver
if they did not have their interlock
device correct absolutely yes okay thank
you
representative newman
uh what what is the state police
definition of a commercial vehicle
because you see
big vehicles that people rent that don't
require a special license to drive them
i just wondered how you what you define
as a commercial vehicle for the purposes
of this law
so for the purposes of this
um
it is
the
definition commercial vehicle it's a
something used in commerce obviously
that has a gross vehicle weight rating
or a combination
vehicle
weight rating greater than ten thousand
pounds
doesn't necessarily require a cdl that's
greater than twenty six thousand pounds
but in this instance uh we're looking at
the broader definition or the federal
definition i i should say of commercial
motor vehicle was
anything greater than ten thousand one
pounds used in the furtherance of a
commercial enterprise
representative muse oh hold on a second
represent a new one you had to follow up
so
can a civilian
driver that doesn't need a cdl rent a
vehicle that fits that those that
description and would they then be
subject to this law no um
the the the big difference with any of
these definitions um
is if they're used in the in the
furtherance of a commercial enterprise
so
technically you could go rent a tractor
trailer an 18-wheeler to move furniture
from one side of the country to the
other and drive it on an operator's
license it's the in-commerce that
kicks all the stuff in
thank you representative muse
thank you for taking my question i am
blessedly not too familiar with
interlocked devices uh but it does
strike me that their a situation with a
commercial driver might be one that
their personal vehicle
has an interlock device and maybe their
and their commercial vehicle uh does not
are these devices portable so if i'm
required to
to have one
can i transfer them from vehicle to
vehicle
i am not aware
if they
if somebody was going to answer that
yeah go ahead
thank you i'll be more than happy to
answer that question as a um
a former agent of the commonwealth of
massachusetts court system for the
purpose of calibrating installing and
maintaining breathalyzer interlock
devices it is not perm it is not
portable and is not designed to be
portable it is permanently fixed into
the motor vehicle and shall be inspected
on a 30-day basis to make sure it hasn't
been tampered with
and i do believe this is a cleanup bill
uh because i assure you that all
probationers other words people that
have these devices ordered by a court in
their motor vehicles are very much aware
of what their requirements are to do
that they shall not operate any motor
vehicle without the interlock device
they know this they've signed off on it
at least a half a dozen times through
their agreements with the courts
and the people and organizations that
provide the equipment so this bill and
correct me if i'm wrong would simply
provide us some recourse against
individuals that may be employed as a
commercial driver
and the rigs that they operate may not
have this they know that they have to
have this equipment in their in whatever
that whatever vehicle they're operating
even a motor vessel
so
this just allows us to keep our roads
safe for people that are being bad
actors and trying to circumvent the
system onto technicality would that be
an uh accurate assessment
yes it would thank you very much thank
you
representative means follow
yeah so
essentially
one of the things that
i'm
also curious about is is a situation um
i guess how common it is for a
commercial vehicle driver
to actually have an employer who would
install one of these things so
it seems like there would be a direct
connection between
a requirement to have a device like this
in any vehicle you operate
and your ability to work if that's what
you do for a living
thank you for the question
and i was surprised
probably six or eight months ago i
received a call in the office um
from a trucking company
looking for the list of providers
because they were hiring a cdl driver
that required an interlock device and um
i had a pretty candid conversation with
with the individual
[Music]
to me
from a law enforcement
perspective
employing a cdl driver
that required an interlock device
obviously means that that person has
some significant history
bad driving history
and
i think of
the amount of insurance that's required
on a commercial vehicle to begin with
and when
you're unemployed
you're employed by a commercial driver
as a commercial driver
all that information is relayed to your
insurance company and that's how they
base some of their premiums is based on
type of vehicle amount of miles driven
and the driving record of your employees
i can only imagine
the
added cost
on to your insurance policy to try to
employ somebody that's got
at least one if not two or more dwi
convictions or another serious offense
on their record um
for whatever reason the this particular
individual for this particular company
was a valued employee and they were
there to support him i don't know that
that would be the case for for most
as you know we're in a nationwide
shortage for cdl drivers
and
we still have a responsibility to make
sure that the people that are driving
these larger vehicles
are responsible and obeying the law
and
they do put them in commercial vehicles
we've seen them before i i i think it's
a huge expense
on the company's part but if they're
willing to do it to support one of their
employees
you know we're there to make sure that
they have the information available to
them i think a lot of us have a question
as to does
does this not disqualify you from a cdl
license at the federal level i mean
having no ui doesn't automatically
prohibit you from getting a cdl license
yes um there are a number of
stipulations that go along with a
conviction for dwi for example in new
hampshire if you're driving your car
snowmobile boat motorcycle and get
convicted of dwi first offense
court will suspend your license for 60
days depending uh six
180 days
if you do certain steps you can get it
back in 90 days if you're a cdl holder
regardless as to what you were driving
at the time
again boat car snowmobile motorcycle
whatever
your cdl is gone for a year
so that's automatic that's
that happens immediately
you can apply to get your
regular operator's license back if you
go through the steps but you can't do
that with your cdl it's a minimum year
so there are a list of
um major infractions if you will
in the federal regulations you know
first offense dwi it's a year second
offense it can be three to five years um
or even a second offense dwi can be a
lifetime banned from
obtaining a cdl so there are significant
penalties even though
you're not operating a commercial
vehicle at the time that you committed
the violation however just because you
have the ability or you have a cdl there
is an enhanced penalty just because you
you hold that license
so the the person you're talking about
the vermont person he would have been
after that one year automatic
and then he was able to do the cdl with
the interlock device
that's correct their their law allows it
as as ours would too
represent wallace thank you mr chairman
and just uh for members know that
commercial people that have commercial
driver's licenses actually have a lower
threshold for
uh being convicted of an oui like us
commercial pilots i don't know exactly
what it is but i believe it's
0.08 for a cdl
so for a regular operator
driving a non-commercial vehicle it's
.08 for somebody driving
a commercial license that requires a cdl
is .04 so it's half
that's only if you're driving something
that requires a cdl license
even though you have a cdl again if you
got caught in your car pickup truck
motorcycle whatever the limit would be
.08 however there again there is the
enhanced penalty once you're convicted
of of it with any other type of vehicle
your cdl is gone for a year
there'd be no further questions we
appreciate the education thank you staff
sergeant
thank you very much the committee now
calls britney shoot from the dmv
good morning members of the committee my
name is brittany shu and i am the bureau
administrator of financial
responsibility this
legislation is at the request of the
department as sergeant huddleston has
informed you there are three pieces to
this legislation and i would like to
speak to all of them further
sergeant huddleston's testimony here but
also to bring attention to
part one of the proposed language
what this allows is the department of
safety to request a hearing on an
individual regardless of whether their
commercial driver and operator who are
convicted of a dwi out of state
so in the state of new hampshire if you
are convicted of a dwi you can be
ordered to have an ignition interlock
device
or you would go to a hearing with bureau
of hearings who would determine whether
you should be a
program participant for an ignition
interlock device
if you're a new hampshire person and you
violate out of state and you get
convicted of a dwi you are not subject
to
the ignition interlock program
through this legislation we'll be able
to bring these individuals in determine
the details of their conviction was it a
first offense was it a subsequent and
should they be a program participant
right now we do not have that authority
so part one of this is applicable to
both commercial and non-commercial
drivers who receive a conviction for dwi
out of state
part two of this legislation
again to further
respond to your questions this provides
the authority for the department of
safety division of motor vehicles
director
to disqualify a commercial driver who
violates the ignition analog program
requirement so if they are operating a
commercial vehicle without an iid the
director does have authority
to disqualify the driver
we must disqualify a driver on a state
level
before it goes to the federal level so
the home state the state of record is
responsible for that disqualification
part three of this further defines a
serious traffic violation
which if a person is operating a vehicle
yes without an id is circumvention
so with this if a person
was charged with this within a two to
three year period they would have a
60-day disqualification it just further
strengthens our ability along with state
police and the roadside troopers to make
sure that our roads are more safe
with commercial motor vehicle drivers
out there
as a sergeant huddleston stated we have
a shortage it is anticipated that we get
more drivers into
these vehicles they help get the country
moving they help get the deliveries out
there but while they're doing that we
want to make sure that should they have
an instance where they do drink and
drive they do lose their license they do
get disqualified and as part of
rehabilitation they are ordered as
participation in the iid program we want
to make sure that they truly are
doing everything that they should be
doing and that we are all safe and that
business is still moving with that i'll
be happy to take any questions
representative
newman thank you
and thank you for your testimony because
it drew my attention back to article one
and so that is somebody who gets an
offense wherever
is then subject to going through a
program that would determine whether
they need an interlock device or not is
that a correct understanding of it thank
you for your question what this
legislation would do is to request a
hearing of that person convicted of a
dwi they would go before the bureau of
hearings to determine the facts and
details and if they are a person that
should be subjected to an ignition
interlock order
thank you
representative burke
thank you mr chairman
this is kind of a two-part is you
explained
part one that we're going to enforce
other states laws here you know if
they're dwi
did the individual
face
uh more punishment back when he got back
into vermont and then the part two is
how many states do this enforce other
state laws
thank you for your question in regards
to the enforcement of state laws new
hampshire is part of the driver
licensing compact so if you are
convicted of a dwi in another
jurisdiction new hampshire will treat it
as if the conviction occurred in new
hampshire
so in regards to this vermont driver
they depend if he get a dwi within the
state of vermont and was subject to the
ignition interlock program in vermont
but was driving in new hampshire
i really can't speak to that because i
don't know if he was convicted in new
hampshire in new hampshire of a dwi
conviction we would apply applicable
state laws and then that home state
whether they choose to take um
reciprocal action under the driver
licensing compact would be up to their
jurisdiction i hope that answers your
question a follow-up
thank you uh but so how many other
states do what we're trying to do here
you know so does vermont enforce new
hampshire let's say the person gets
arrested here in new hampshire and he
goes over in
vermont and drives will does vermont
have this particular law to punish him
i do not have a specific answer but i
will be more than happy to research that
for you thank you
and i have a question just so you could
clarify it please
this isn't necessarily proposing that we
enforce other state laws it's proposing
that we
recognize a conviction in another state
and apply our own laws to is that is
that proper understanding okay thank you
representative newman thank you this is
just a follow-up to my previous question
so i'm not sure if you described this
example but it's
someone from out of state who had a dwi
in any jurisdiction and then gets
stopped
would they then become in new hampshire
would they then become subject to
hearing in new hampshire or what how
would that work
are you talking about a new hampshire
driver
it could be an out-of-state driver
i think i think a new hampshire driver
you would you would be subject to the
laws and it would automatically happen
i'm just wondering how this law the way
it was written would affect
an out-of-state driver that had a dwi
and i don't know whether how they would
know that maybe they'd do it when they
run the license okay thank you for
claiming what would happen so
i will attempt to answer that so in the
state of new hampshire if you're an
out-of-state driver and you are
convicted of dwi
statutorily
for the ignition interlock program it
has to be a subsequent so
in that case if you're statutorily
required for the dwi conviction as say a
massachusetts driver in new hampshire we
can order ignition interlocks for people
that reside in another jurisdiction who
are convicted of dwi in new hampshire
representative true thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
ma'am um
if this had happened
what this bill is addressing it happened
in new hampshire
and and the person lost their license
their cdl license for at least a year
after they heard on testimony
it would be the state of new hampshire
that would tell this person after a year
you can now activate your cdl
thank you for your question
the home state is the only state that
this can disqualify a commercial driver
so a vermont driver that comes to new
hampshire as sergeant huddleston was
stating we can cite them for operating
outside of the ignition interlock what
we can't do is we cannot disqualify the
vermont driver what we can do is report
that information back to the home
jurisdiction who would then take action
in accordance with their laws what this
does here is this provides the authority
for the new hampshire division of motor
vehicles to disqualify a new hampshire
commercial driver
for the operating a commercial motor
vehicle without an ignition interlock
when subject to an ignition interlock
thank you mr g and thank you man
let's say this happened to me in new
hampshire
i was supposed i have a cdl i'm supposed
to have an interlock device
and i'm driving a cdl vehicle without
the interlock
and i'm found guilty of that
would i lose my cdl license in new
hampshire
yes this provides me the authority to
disqualify you as a driver for
not complying with the ignition
interlock requirement
this this bill does yes it provides me
the authority to do that thank you thank
you
there'd be no
uh representative harriet gathering
so thank you for your question if a
person is operating a commercial motor
vehicle as sergeant huddleston indicated
we would only be able to cite them for
the 62 violation of not obeying the
restrictions on their license
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony
as anyone else here who wish to speak on
this bill was not signed up
[Music]
there being none i am going to close the
public hearing on hp 1246.
we have
i'm going to go ahead and try and
exec maybe one bill um
pass these out i've got an amendment i'm
going to pass around
yeah
it's it's the notorious purple paint
bill 1108
huh
um
we're going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1108 and the
committee recognizes representatives
and i broke the whole thing
my bill will be in the mail
i am introducing an amendment to um
representative reed's bill
hb 1108 the purple paint bill um
so we heard testimony about it we heard
from the environmental
police we heard um from some landowners
i think all of us have seen some emails
on this
um
i think that there was some some good in
this bill
in my opinion
um for
an elderly person
or someone who can't get around good the
to have to go out and put these signs up
every 100 yards and maintain them is
very difficult and expensive
also at the same time allowing people to
just run around putting purple paint
um leads to other issues um that could
hurt hunters
and people just wanting to enjoy the
outdoors
so i felt like a compromise was in order
so this is what we came up with
right now currently you have to have a
sign every 100 yards in the woods
with your name address and information
on it
this amendment would make it so that you
had to have a sign every 250 yards so
i've more than doubled it
but in between that you can put purple
paint on the trees
so if you're in the woods you're a
hunter you're just an outdoor enthusiast
if you see purple paint you know that
you don't have to walk more than 100
yards in either direction and you'll
know who owns the land and if it's
properly posted
or not
so i think that's a compromise for
landowners outdoorsman hunters everybody
that will make it easier on property
owners in new hampshire
to be able to mark their property if
they so choose
um also there was concerns about people
just running around willy-nilly spray
painting purple paint everywhere
i've added a
punishment if they do that um if you're
caught
spray painting property that's not yours
and you don't have written landowner
permission
first offense be a misdemeanor
second would be a class b felony um and
you'd be responsible for going and
fixing all the trees you damaged um and
if that means you're going to walk
around and spray paint them brown again
that's it's up to the court to decide
but
so i've given it some teeth and i've
made a compromise i hope that you all
think about it
and that's i'll take any questions
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative just a quick question the
the signs that are up now
refresh my memory are they are they yet
like the posted signs are they yellow
or or what color are they i i think i'm
not sure someone can correct me if they
i think they just have to be white i'm
not sure if they have to be yellow they
just have to be a certain size there's a
certain measurement and certain
information that has to be on them
does anyone know if it's going to be
yellow follow up
so would it
i'm just thinking if when i was here
when we were listening this bill and
there was a lot of confusion over the
different colors and people don't know
what purple was and i remember the the
people from like the forest industry
were here speaking about that
would it be
i guess i'm thinking would it be
if they're going to use spray paint
instead of making like elderly like
you're saying i see that point would it
be better just have it all be the same
color instead of changing it to the
color purple
i think the purple thing is because
there are numerous states that have
adopted it so it's starting to pick up
and starting to gain knowledge i think
is where the purple came from
representative testament
i don't know how to put this be gentle
this i'm going to oppose this i think
this is a
ludicrous bill
so the question really is you know why
are we wasting time on this
i guess i would ask the chair why are
you letting him talk to me that way but
i'm gonna go ahead and
i'm gonna pass him
um
i'll tell you this we should
as a committee we could have dealt with
this a week ago and in the meantime it's
generated a lot of public interest um i
myself have received hundreds of emails
and at least 70 from my own constituents
that like the idea so
i'm here to do my constitutional
spitting and they wanted it so they got
it
representative welch
yes i'm going to support this
not because i'm really enthusiastic
about it
but if we amend the bill this will be
the bill that we'll hear in a session
and that will be far better than the
original
representative muse
thank you for taking my question um
taking a look at our criminal mischief
law um we have a maximum
uh it look it it looks like what you may
have tried to do is to try to mirror
the um
are crim
marry the penalties for violation of
this particular law so
um
uh spray painting purple paint without
permission
um
uh
were you trying to mirror uh the
criminal mischief law
to some extent but this is uh is its own
um it's its own offense with different
ramifications on criminal mischief law
the ramifications for this could be um
if you were to do it without permission
um
you know if you walked around and spray
painted a couple hundred acres of trees
to and you didn't have permission to do
it the ramifications are far more than
just criminal mischief that's a lot of
work and expense to fix that so i felt
like a second offense after you've been
properly warned
don't spray paint people's property
without permission um
in the cost of doing it i felt justified
a little bit stiffer of a penalty for a
second offense
follow-up representative muse
it's one of the things that that does
concern me is if you if you look at the
criminal mischief statute which is 634
colon 2.
it is a lot more specific about how
the initial how the misdemeanor penalty
would be applied versus the
the the class b felony penalty and
i guess is is your feeling that
we might need
more of that type of detail in this
amendment before we act on it
um i think that it applies equally to
both the first and second offense i
don't see where the the specification or
the specificity drops off it just says
that the second offense will be a felony
versus a misdemeanor if you're asking me
about the um the specificity as far as
paying for fixing the damage done
but let's
let's um
i raise it just simply because it looks
it looks like what you're what you're
trying to do is to turn
um illegally spraying paint into really
a form of criminal mischief and i was
just wondering if it would make more
sense just to reference the existing
statute
than to put potentially conflicting
language into the statute
i don't know we could discuss that let
me let me go back to the chair unless
you have another question about
representative bourdain
maybe it'd be more appropriate if we
just open it up to the executive
discussion for the session
yeah representative burt
uh thank you
mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question
have you ran this by
and do you have support of forest and
lands new hampshire forest and lands
jason stock new hampshire timber
association a land association and fish
and game that oppose this because they
tried it in maine and they're the
laughing stock
i have the support from the fish and
game said they supported the compromise
i did not discuss it with the um the
timber people
i have the support of my constituents i
know that
so
whether the timber folks like it or not
i know that it's being done across the
country in many states
whether how mane healed i don't know
and one follow-up follow-up thank you mr
chairman and
i am looking at the penalty phase
yes which
you know i support people should be
punished if they harm other people's
property
um the first time is a class a
misdemeanor
i believe that's a year in jail could be
maximum yeah max yep and i think up to a
thousand dollar fine but then the next
fine is
removal of your guns
if you're convicted of a felon
so that concerns me because i'm thinking
you know the graffiti on the billboards
that we see everywhere and on buildings
i don't think it's even a felon there
so i want to check that out before you
know hopefully i can check that out
before we go to a vote but where is the
fiscal note on this because there is a
huge fiscal note now that should be
applied to this
so we can pass this amendment
with with regard to the incarceration
right yeah they didn't um they didn't
give me one so we can send it back and
ask for one they would probably go to
finance i guess anyway
with regard to your question about the
the different punishment versus you know
losing guns and stuff
frankly i gotta be honest if you're
convicted once or spray painting
somebody else's property so that people
can't go on it and then you do it again
intentionally the consequences are well
known to you and you you reap what you
sow
um
i don't have a question i mean i don't
have a question i just have commentary
i'm
this is an executive session right so i
don't think that the format of having a
person
like giving testimony is correct i think
just some feedback
i think that we're free to all just
discuss the bill however we'd like and
we don't need to um
[Music]
we don't need to treat representative
roy like a like a like a witness as the
chairman as the daryl would normally say
um
and so in that vein since it's just
exact session and we just talk about
what we think of the bill because if it
was a public hearing it would need to be
properly noticed correct which it has
been but in that vein i just wanted to
mention that it makes sense to just
knicks uh section three
if that's not too bad and
i would recommend just pausing and
getting something new from ols it seems
like it's pretty straightforward based
on what i'm hearing point well taken the
process was to have representative rory
introduced a bill and have a work
session which is what we're doing it's a
bit ad hoc but uh yeah we're getting the
work done so yeah i'd like to go back to
my sheet though because i'm feeling very
uncomfortable and attacked up here
i'm sorry i believe work sessions also
need to be noticed in the calendar
is that
did i
if this is a work session it needs to be
noticed
but if it's an exact session on the
bottom of this executive session on
pending legislation may be held
throughout the day
i believe we can actually so it's
probably trying to clarify that it can't
be a workshop it's on today's notice
what we're going to do is we're going to
go ahead i think
yeah i'm going to recess the executive
session it sounds like
there's some support
some not um and i will uh
i'll work on that and we'll come back
with it after
so i'm gonna recess the executive
session
and now we will stand in recess until 10
o'clock
let me start with the uh
good morning
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on house bill
1085 relative to ignition lock
requirements
first signed up to speak representative
laura tolavsky
good morning
thank you mr chairman and thank you
colleagues
for the record i'm laura talersky and i
represent hillsborough 35 which is
nashua ward 8.
today i present for your consideration
house bill 1085 relative to ignition
lock requirements
the issue this bill addresses first came
to my attention back in 2020 in the form
of hb 1465
when representative sykes submitted the
bill at the request of the dmv
it came out of house transportation with
an ought to pass motion and passed the
full house on the consent calendar on
that now infamous house session on march
11th and 12th 2020.
from there it was lost to covid in the
senate where it died on the table
several months ago i had a conversation
with director bilecki about dmv bills
that had been lost to covid and she
asked if this bill could be filed again
i won't go into too much detail on the
uh interlock devices since the previous
bill also addressed what they actually
are
but briefly an ignition intellect device
is a small handheld breathalyzer for car
ignitions that is installed to prevent
users from starting their vehicle after
drinking alcohol
what this bill does is clarify the
language
on which vehicle needs one of these
devices
if i can direct your attention to the
bill on line five
it reads that a device should be
installed quote in any vehicle
registered to that person
or used by that person quote on a
regular basis
it's that phrase on a regular basis that
is the problem
i think we can all agree
that if you own a car and it's the
primary car you use to drive to and from
work that car is used on a regular basis
therefore that vehicle will need an
interlock device
but what about the car that is
registered to your spouse that you only
drive on weekends
technically is that on a regular basis
would you need an interlock device on
that car
then perhaps you borrow your friend's
car to run an errand or maybe use your
neighbor's pickup on the weekend to make
a run to the dump
again both of those scenarios
would your vehicle
need an interlock device
because are you using it on a regular
basis
this bill simply strikes out that
problematic phrase
clearly changing the statute to reflect
that an interlocked device must be
installed on any car
used by a person who has been convicted
of a dwi offense
when in the process of reinstatement of
their license if ordered by the court
in layman's terms this clarifies the
intent
and closes an unintended loophole that
currently exists
it's my hope that this committee will
see hb 1085 as a simple language cleanup
and find this bill ought to pass thank
you
representative newman
thank you
could you just clarify if this
bill as we see it here and where the
language is stricken
was that language stricken in the
previous bill and this is just a clean
up of the previous bill as it was or is
this in addition to what may have been
on the bill that was left on the table
thank you for the question
representative newman uh this is the
exact bill that died on the table in the
senate it just was never uh able to be
brought up and presented to the senate
thank you
representative boardney
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um
so this bill now requires that
if i am required to use an intellect
device on my vehicle
and i have three vehicles only one of
which i drive
all three vehicles have to have
interlock devices
that's what the intent of this bill
would be that if you potentially have
three vehicles in your possession
this would mean that every vehicle you
could potentially drive
would need to have an interlock or any
vehicle
you
ever sit behind the wheel and turn the
ignition
representative bourdain recognized for
follow-up
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question um
wouldn't it be
easier and better to require that
anybody that is required to have an
interlock device
while they're driving to
be have an interlock on device that
they're driving
versus having all their vehicles have
interlocked devices
thank you i think i'm
maybe mis uh answered your previous
question then um this bill is the way i
understand it and i'm sure that there
might be someone who would testify after
me
cleans it up to say that any vehicle
a person drives would need an interlock
device if they have been so ordered by
the court
whereas the existing statute has that
loophole where it says
in any vehicle you drive on a regular
basis
thank you
representative testerman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
isn't the the reason
for this bill
or for a bill like this
is to make sure that people
you know have an interlock device
if they're driving a vehicle
i think i tend to agree with
representative boardney
that
that's the issue it's
covering all the cars
if he doesn't drive him or if he only
has one that has interlocked that's the
one he ought to drive
and if if he gets stopped you know he's
got a penalty but i can't see
and do you think that we ought to
require everything that he has a
potential of getting in
because it happens to be owned by him or
a friend is a logical way to do it
thank you for the question this bill
does not
mean
someone who is subject to an interlock
needs to install an interlock device on
every vehicle registered to him it
simply says that any vehicle he drives
must have an interlock device
representative harry gathering
sorry
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question if you look at line
23 it absolutely says in any vehicle
register
to the person
and i think that's what they're
referring to because it does say that or
used by that person
so it does say for me i have three cars
so i would have to have an interlock on
all three whether i'm driving it or not
that's what this bill says
thank you and i agree with you that is
what it says and that is what the
statute states now
the only change this bill is going to
make is to clarify that any vehicle
that
someone subjective to this uh intellect
device order
any vehicle they drive would need an
interlock device
representative boardney i think we need
to fix it
thank you thank you for taking my
question
does vehicle in this case only mean
automobile does it include snowmobile
and our
boats
thank you for the question i may have to
defer to someone in the dmv
on that question
representative greene
thank you for taking my question what
about motorcycles
i again would defer but i would assume
that um a motorcycle would fall under
the regular
motor vehicle uh statutes
representative sue newman
yes thank you
excuse me thank you for taking the
question i just glanced very quickly at
what costs for
interlock devices are installation
servicing
or whatever
installing servicing and then removing
it
it can get very expensive
i i would think i'm i'm not opposed to
this i'm i'm just thinking
there's a question here
oh
i'm struggling with it it's there is a
question
a question would be as a public service
with
people being against dwi
exposing the cost of all of this might
be a d
could be a
it could be a deterrent that's not a
very good question but i'm done thank
you
i'm not i'm not sure that there was a
question there
i was still waiting for it
thank you representative newman
if i may if the chair may inquire with
the question and
so if i was convicted hypothetically of
an aggravated dwi fan so i would have to
put interlock device to my own vehicle
if uh
you were gracious enough to let me
borrow your vehicle
what would happen in that scenario
under
today's statute
my interpretation would be that you
would be able to drive my car because
you don't drive my car on a regular
basis
this bill
what i understand
would close that loophole
and
it said that you would need to use it
by that person
period
thank you
representative conley
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative is the intent of this
bill
solely that somebody who is required to
be operating with an interlock device
uses an interlock device when they
operate a motor vehicle
yes thank you for the question the point
of this is to make sure that anyone who
is subjective to the order of using an
intellect device must use an intellect
device on any vehicle that they get
behind the wheel and turn the ignition
on and start driving
representative roy thank you and just to
follow up on representative conley
this bill does not mandate installation
of extra interlock devices and vehicles
it just mandates that the driver
only use one that has an interlock
device is that correct
thank you for the question um in the
previous bill um someone stated that if
someone's subjected to this order they
understand what it means and they
learn all the rules
and i believe that this bill simply
codifies one of those rules which is you
need to use an intellect device if
you're driving that's what this bill
does it makes sure that someone who
should not be driving with anything
other than an intellect device
cannot it does not mean that they need
to go install one on their
mother-in-law's vehicle or their
neighbor's vehicle
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
good morning mr chairman
good morning
uh thank you
uh just briefly um
we with the department of safety state
police um
support this um the testimony we've just
heard covers
basically everything i was gonna say uh
other than this is to make sure that
any vehicle that a person subject to
this
regulation
operates a vehicle that has an interlock
device in it
basically we're just trying to make sure
that
they're complying with what the court
has mandated
representative welch
thank you mr chairman
do you think that it would be worthwhile
if somebody's convicted
and is subject to having an intellect
device that if there's four cars
registered in that family that all the
license plates should be marked
that's a
unique question
i don't know that
i think somebody from the civilian
civil liberties union would probably
have a problem with that
um marking marking somebody uh that way
i
i don't know that we would support that
further question
representative welch recognized for a
follow-up
uh
back along oh several years back we had
a judge come up here from ohio
and in ohio they had a deal where
everybody in that household
got a yellow license plate
which meant that
during the
anytime they saw that car with a yellow
license plate they could stop it to
check to make sure that it wasn't the
convicted driver
driving it
and that
in some families
you have an enabler who allows the let's
say the husband is a drunk
and the wife puts up with it and the
wife has to go grocery shopping and
there's a shame attached to that
i think they have elected judges in ohio
and i don't know how that judge survived
but
that was a scenario
it was to make the
uh
try to convince the guy who was drinking
all the time to not drink
that's certainly a novel approach
but seeing that there was not a question
i i'll leave it to the witness to
and just just
we'll just cover this now
members are recognized to ask questions
of the witness to obtain information
either about the testimony or about the
bill
we are not permitted to debate the
witness and let's not make
uh generalized statements even if i
agree with the statement you're making
it's not it's not um
in order for that to happen so i would
just ask that
we make it through the day without
having to bring this up again
representative bourdain
so can you define vehicle
does it apply to snowmobiles and
boats and motorcycles
in this instance yes the term vehicle is
any motorized
motor transportation wouldn't be a
bicycle but snowmobile motorcycle boat
atv utv any anything that was
that's motorized
representative boarding
thank you chair thank you for protecting
my question uh our intellect
uh interlock devices available for
all all these types of vehicles
i believe they are
obviously they're not as
common as one for a regular passenger
vehicle but yes my understanding is that
they can be installed on anything
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony
oh representative
harry katherine has a question for the
witness if you don't mind um
i realize that um
the um
the information that i asked about on
line 23
and i thank um representative tulerski
for
helping me to remember that this is
already in the bill but would you have a
problem in taking that piece out what
that refers to line 23 where it refers
to
all cars owned by the person
so what you're asking is that would we
oppose
the
language that said any vehicle
registered to that person striking that
and just have it to be
say any vehicle used by the person
exactly
i don't know that we would oppose that
um
because yeah you
there are people that
use vehicles that aren't registered to
them on a daily basis as well so
i don't know that we would oppose
that
that's that's the first i've heard of
that though
thank you thank you
representative uh thank you mr chairman
uh would you agree with me that that
language also appears in line five and
would need to be amended there
yes
no
somebody else will speak to that
in a minute
thank you for your testimony
this is just my interpretation the
difference between line five and lines
23 lines 23 applies to
someone who's under the age of 21 where
lines five would apply to i presumably
someone over the age 21. that's just how
i read it
sorry
well
when there's a subsection that's
different that specifically addresses
the age 21 and under
i would interpret that if the prior
section would not apply
okay and it only applies to aggravated
this is involving an individual that has
an aggravated dwi
offense or has had a subsequent offense
conviction
anyone may correct me if i read that
wrong
clerk may call the next witness
on house bill 1085 we next call britney
shoot dmv
morning members of the committee a lot
of great conversation going on here and
i'm hoping that i can provide some
clarification um to your questions the
best of my ability and if i cannot i
will be certainly happy to mark those uh
questions and get back to you
this bill
is at the request of the department and
yes
removing on a regular basis does help
clarify two people subjected to the
program that they can only drive a
vehicle equipped with an
iid there are instances again where this
is my wife's car i'm running to the
store
um what it does is it makes it
consistent with the subsequent um
chapter 2637 which is our convention and
that states any vehicle technically a
person who's operating a vehicle without
an iid that's their convention
so what we want to do is strengthen this
program and make sure that it's clear to
those program participants what their
expectations are and that there's no
ambiguity in the law to prosecutors and
the program participants law enforcement
it really brings the program all
together to make sure everyone
understands their responsibilities
because as mentioned these ignition
interlock devices can be costly to a
person
and what this is saying is that if a
vehicle is registered to a person they
have to have an id if this person is
using the vehicle on a regular basis
or actually removing that if they're
using a vehicle so in a household with a
husband and wife situation
let's just say vehicles register the
husband and another vehicle registered
to the wife if that vehicle is
registered to the wife and the husband
is not using that vehicle does not touch
it does not think about it doesn't even
think about thinking about it
they do not need to install a device
what the person's responsibility is is
to drive a vehicle that is equipped with
an ignition interlock device
it's really important that they are
complying with their restriction
so to answer some questions here
in regards to marking a person's plate
it is technically already in statute
that the department can mark a person's
plate do we practice that no
in regards to line 23 yes it's pursuant
to people who are under the age of 21.
if a person is under the age of 21 and
has multiple vehicles registered to them
and they're drinking and driving we
really need to make sure that we are
focusing on that person to make sure
that they're complying with the program
and that they're rehabilitating in a
proper way
why yes it can be monetarily
expensive to that person if they're only
driving one vehicle and they only have
one vehicle registered to them
they are at the same as any other person
who is subject to an ignition interlock
device
with that i'll be happy to take any
questions
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question could you give us a figure
what it would cost a person in one year
to have that device put on their vehicle
great question
i'm actually going to have um this
gentleman here come up and answer that
question specifically so you have better
information if you don't mind
since you're here
there's two seats there for a reason
thank
you
for the record uh my name is robert
blaisdell and i represent consumer
safety technology
in tuxelok we're out of des moines iowa
and i've been involved with this
program ever since the early 2000s
ever all the way back to the rfp process
to answer your question representative
my understanding is it's for the
installation it's roughly about 150
for the daily cost
it can depend um
it's anywhere between two dollars and
fifty cents to three dollars a day
um what we're finding though is that
some of these costs
um are are rising to like cars such as
like teslas for example or it's a little
bit more complicated
um but that's that's roughly what i'm
aware of it's 150 to put it on 150 to
take it off
and then
roughly 2.50 3 a day
representative pratt
um
if you didn't have this i id
system in place the appropriate thing
would be to take the person's license
for a long period of time correct this
is a multiple offense
thank you for your question
in the scenario when a person is subject
to an ignition interlock order they do
not have the ability to wait it out they
must comply with the compliance
requirement which is the installation if
they are so ordered by the department of
safety or the new hampshire court system
what i meant to say was uh
if nearly quite follow-up recognize for
a follow-up thank you
what i meant to say is we didn't have
this whole program in place the iid
the appropriate thing to do for somebody
who's been convicted for drinking after
ratification or not having a license
would be to say they couldn't drive
period for a number of periods of years
or whatever
thank you for your question a person
who's convicted of dwi
would serve out their suspension period
if they are then caught operating after
suspension or revocation yes there's
additional additional sanctions and if a
person chooses not to install an
ignition inner lock device as a
condition of restoration then they will
indefinitely remain suspended until they
comply good thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
pardon my voice um
i i think there's just a little
confusion and i i want to clear it up
why are we getting involved in you know
which vehicle or this vehicle uh versus
just focusing on the operator and saying
you cannot drive a vehicle i don't care
what it is without an interlock device
and then putting the penalty on the
driver why are we starting to get into
which vehicle has what and installation
and all this stuff if the if the
driver's only able to drive with an
interlock device
bottom line
why why even get into the vehicles
i think that is a great question thank
you
the focus is on the operator of the
vehicle and making sure that they
understand their expectations that they
cannot operate a vehicle
without ignition interlock device
follow-up
representative roy recognized for a
follow-up so
the the bill
needn't only say uh an operator subject
to an uh an interlock device may not
operate any vehicle that does not have
an interlock device is that not simple
enough just like that
thank you for your follow-up i think
that is fair language and we are
certainly open to addressing the ways
that we can ensure that people
are only operating
a vehicle when they have an iid order
and taking the ambiguity out of the law
and making sure that there isn't that
space for them to say well i don't
operate this vehicle on a regular basis
okay
thank you
representative true
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh i know it's
in the rsa now however
in three places in the bill it's
mentioned that and any vehicle
registered to the person
what would be your department's position
on removing
the wording and that you have to put
this in any vehicle registered
is do you see that as a problem
thank you for your question are you
asking if we put any vehicle registered
to them
no if if we strike if we strike that if
if that were in an amendment if that
were removed
the wording
that they had to uh put this device in
any vehicle registered to them
i'm asking because as you said the the
purpose is
to make sure the person under this court
order follows
that he doesn't drive any vehicle
without a device installed in the
vehicle
i think that is a great question and i
think i would need to further assess
that to
give a
a better answer
um because again we have to understand
in totality how that impacts the driver
and their vehicles and what they're
doing on the roadways
thank you thank you
representative connolly thank you and
not to belabor this but
the representative who just asked a
question
or maybe it was just before said if we
clarify the law to say that
somebody subject to these requirements
uses this device when they drive does
that not meet the criteria and the goal
of this bill rather than getting into
however many vehicles they own and so
forth
you ha you
does that clear it is that clarity
something that we can cert that we can
go for
yes absolutely and i apologize i see how
the answer for here and there um i just
want to make sure that when we adjust
this law that we're adjusting correctly
and yes what you guys are saying is the
fact that it's the owner well not the
owner the person that is subject to the
order and compliance with that order so
yes thank you
representative ray newman
thank you
um
for my identification could you just
clarify how
a person who has to drive with an inter
excuse me interlock device
how that affects their ability to drive
and how the thing works
when they have to use it
the short answer representative is
um
nothing gets affected so long as they're
not under the influence
the longer answer is
how it affects
their their situation um
they are subject to having to blow into
the device prior to starting they are
also subject to a random
rolling retest um and that's just to
prevent the example of okay i'm sober
now but i got my six-pack ready to go
here they they know that they're going
to be subject to at any given time
um so that's that's i guess the um to
the extent of that's how it impacts them
representative ray newman recognized for
a follow-up
thank you so that information is that
information recorded
somewhere when it happens that the
person now has finished the six-pack
and
the car is then disabled i understand i
assume
and then is that information who is that
information available
to and how how does that affect
sure their situation okay so a couple of
things um
when when there is a a violation it's um
everything is recorded and it's i
believe the law says that it has to be
sent in or transmitted in real time is
that
that's for the for the enhanced version
um
so yes there is uh there's a whole
communication system set up between the
the various vendors and the department
so that there's violation reports and
and and whatnot um you mentioned about
disabling the vehicle i want to be
absolutely clear here that during um a
random rolling retest when they're going
down 93
the car isn't automatically disabled um
it's what happens then at that point is
is if there's a violation they need to
turn over because it's there's a
violation the horn is blaring and then
there would be a lockout for a period of
time
thank you
sorry thank you um thank you again for
the opportunity so i'm as i'm reading
through this and taking into
consideration the idea is brought forth
we want to make sure that the spirit of
the ignition interlock is installed so
if we are proposing that after a period
of revocation or suspension to install
an ignition interlock device as defined
in rsa 259 49a
in any vehicle used by that person for
not less than 12 months
representative testament
if
if you install something for not less
than 12 months
and that's outside the period of his
sentence
is that's the right thing to do i mean
why are you leaving it on there i'm not
sure if i heard that correctly
thank you for your question that is just
where i stopped reading in the statute
there's at minimum or 12-month
compliance and depending on violations
depending on the 24-month depending on
circumvention it can be in a vehicle for
a much longer duration what's important
is to recognize that a device must be
installed in a vehicle that a person
uses in order to be in compliance with
the ignition interlock program so while
we are speaking about the driver
specifically there is a vehicle
installation aspect to the ignition
interlock program
thank you for your testimony the
chairman inquire with a question
can do can you provide the committee any
examples of
what an aggravated dui offense would
entail
thank you for your question an
aggravated dwi offense
would be somebody that had a blood
alcohol
breath alcohol concentration greater
than um a 1 6.
legal limits point zero eight
aggravated be 1.6 so and out
basically double what the
um minimum is
also if they
tried to elude
the police
was involved in a
crash that
resulted in
bodily injury any of those are
aggravating
factors which would then
make it an aggravated dwi
thank you for taking my question
representative greene
uh is there any
uh
what am i trying to think of
circumstances and like there where new
hampshire may remove a person's
registration their plates and their
license for a period
yes
there are a number of
different scenarios that would
allow the division of motor vehicles to
do that um
i know there are a number of things that
could that could occur but yes that that
is a possibility
okay thank you thank you
thank you for your testimony
are there any members of the public who
wish to testify
that are present who have not testified
already
seeing no hands at this time will now
close the
public hearing on house bill 1085.
the committee will be in in recess to
10 45.
quiet please we're going to open the
public hearing on house bill
1333 fn
we asked the prime sponsor
representative abbas
to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman
my name is uh i'm representative daryl
abbess i
i represent rockingham county district
eight
and this for the members on the who
served on the committee uh last term
with with myself
we this bill actually passed in
committee
uh
out with a positive recommendation
however it was unceremoniously tabled
um
over my objection so i re i have now
refiled the same exact bill
when you turn on the news
sometimes you'll hear a news report
about someone who's been arrested and
convicted of their fifth or sixth drunk
driving conviction and people always
wonder how does that happen how does
this person still have a driver's
license
in new hampshire when a subsequent
offense is prosecuted
there's a look-back period the look-back
period
for all the offenses is 10 years
so the third
fourth fifth offense would all have to
happen within a ten year
time period
what this bill would do it simply would
extend the look back time period for the
third in fourth offenses uh the
rationale for that is uh quite often the
third and fourth offense don't occur
within that the ten-year window and
during that ten years especially with
someone who's been now convicted two
times of
drunk driving
that person's license has been suspended
for a large portion of that time period
so this is really this is really
addressed to
repeat offenders
specifically third and fourth offenders
and it would just simply extend that
look-back period in that limited
circumstance it does not prevent
someone from obtaining an annulment of a
conviction
which is a 10-year time period for any
drunk driving conviction and if a person
were to get in that conviction annulled
it would still it would not necessarily
mean that wouldn't count towards the
subsequent offense so that was the
purpose of this bill was really to
address
repeat offenders and we're talking third
and fourth offen offenders not
first and seconds
and
personally
the way i look at it is if an individual
is continuing to break the law
especially commit the same offense
that they've already been convicted for
in two occasions one that person is
engaging in behavior that creates a
risk in danger to public safety
at the same time
it's it also shows that person has not
been rehabilitated
at all by the punishment or penalty for
a first and second offense
so i would hope passing the committee
last term i hope again it passes
this time i hope it passes in the house
and no one makes a motion to table it
and i'll of course
answer any questions
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you have the house
bill from last year but
i was in the process of looking that up
if you give me about
15 seconds i'll tell you right now thank
you
the house bill from last last term was
hb
1654.
representative bordenay
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh in your testimony you uh
said that
if a conviction was
annulled then
that would still count
how's that going to be counted and i
didn't see any reference into
in the language of the bill about
annulment of convictions
being an exception
last term and i believe it was
if i'm going off a memory it was
senate bill 311 and that the as
as it came to the committee last term
it involved the annulments of several
different areas but one of the one of
the
sections of that bill was specifically
um drunk driving convictions and the
look they wanted that wanted to reduce
the look back period not i shouldn't say
look back period the time period from
the date of your conviction to when a
person would be eligible to get an
annulment but in that in the language in
the existing law is if you get a
offense
if you get an annulment of an offense it
doesn't necessarily
negate it from counting as a subsequent
towards subsequent offenses
that's that's just what we were what
what is as written now can you prove
it can a sub a prior offense when it's
been annulled that it that could be
rather difficult
that's that's a that can be challenging
because you would have to prove
the conviction and if you don't have
access to the records it can be hard to
do
there was some disagreement
between myself and the uh
well-known unh uh law professor that
frequents here very
very frequently we disagreed on how that
would be proven in a court of law but
that's what to look back here this
wouldn't affect that
by any means and i'm not trying to
address the annulment issue all right
thank you i i have no further questions
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question um
something i'm just interested in some
clarification on is um
it appears at the bottom of the bill
there's some language that would include
an out-of-state conviction as one of the
offenses that would qualify as a third
or fourth offense
is is that true and and how do things
like out-of-state convictions uh
uh change uh with this particular bill
so my understanding is that for
the purposes of considering subsequent
offenses and specifically for drunk
driving
it's the practice of the overall i think
i want to say every state will consider
out-of-state convictions
when it comes to whether it's a
subsequent offense or not
for new hampshire's purposes again we
have a limited look-back period every
state has a different look-back period
some some states have an unlimited
look-back period period
so
this is really what this is focusing on
is
it can count out-of-state convictions
but i don't believe that that would
change the look-back period
at all it just
whether it's a second third or fourth
offense
it would take into consideration
out-of-state conviction
and a lot of driving laws will factor in
out-of-state convictions
so i i guess just to clarify for me
because i'm i'm less familiar with our
drunk driving laws than i probably
should be
um
but um under current new hampshire law
uh
our
our out-of-state convictions um actually
counted
as uh as as prior convictions so for
instance
um if we're looking at determining uh
let's say whether somebody's been
convicted three times
would a conviction in massachusetts or
vermont count as one of those
convictions that would trigger that part
of our law
my understanding is that the
out-of-state conviction will
be considered provided it's it's the
equivalence so if the legal limit is .08
or higher let's just say for the sake of
argument another state their legal limit
was point
one one two
if you
i think i have to go the opposite
direction my whole point is it would
have to also be consistent with our laws
so
if you if let's just say that it was .06
in vermont which it's not but let's just
say that it is if you've got a drunk
driving convictions and your
blood alcohol content was .06
although you violated vermont law
because it's not the reason
the equivalent of the new hampshire law
my reading of this is that that would
not actually count as a prior offense
because of the blood alcohol content
difference
i'm not aware but i'm not aware of any
state that does not have point zero
eight
thank you
would it um question i
wouldn't it uh under the um
under the um
i don't know if it's the equal
protection what is the there's a i think
my constitutional laws fail me right now
but the uh the the where we recognize
the laws of other states i believe that
would that not cover that
i believe you're
referring to the full faith and credit
clause that's the one
i
without getting into getting into the
that constitutional principle it's very
common that when it comes to drunk drunk
driving convictions that you factor and
you consider other
out-of-state convictions
and
that's something that a lot of the
states kind of joined together as an
issue of safety purposes
representative bordenay
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question again
i'm looking at line one and page two
and it
uh says occurring more than 10 years
with
after the date of the present offense
isn't that in
that's indefinite isn't it
should that be within
uh 10 years
let me read it sure
let me as you don't mind if i may read
it in
the chair so grace will let you
ask the same question
page two
i'm on my way
is are you pointing out is your question
is that a drafting error
i'm asking if that's the intent or is it
are are not
i think it would have to be before
so this is only for offenses
after 10 years
forever
the
the intent is for that to be within the
10 year time period not forever
i'm aware and i'm very thankful that my
my friend from
keene was so kind to point that out
i'm even i'm even more thankful that he
serves on on this great committee with
me so we can work together to fix that
and actually you know
i will take the i'll take the heat for
this i believe representative welch
uh pointed this out last year and it's
the same as before
but but i'm glad i'm glad everyone was
uh
on their toes and caught that
representative ray newman
reference that same line
after it's corrected
would and there is a penalty associated
with that of a class a misdemeanor
so if someone had a
dwi offense first offense in that time
period
is that the same penalty or it seems to
be in bold or has the penalty been
changed do you know
it's it's inquiring it's dealing with a
prior a subsequent conviction so that
would be the second offense is a
what i understand any class a
misdemeanor
thank you
there be no further questions oh there
is one representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um i believe you said that
in new hampshire we already take into
consideration
out of state convictions
when you when you're adding up the
number of offenses
that being the case
why do we need section b
page on
on line 28
if we already do that
i think what this is doing it's
clarifying the look back period that's
my that's my understanding what the
purpose of that section is
is how far do you go back in time
from one where you're going to consider
a prior
prior offense so if you have a
conviction then 30 years later you get a
second
that won't be considered but i think
it's
when considering the out-of-state you
want to make sure the look-back period
is the same
thank you
no further questions thank you for your
testimony
thank you mr chairman
anyone from the public who wishes to
testify who hasn't signed up to testify
there being none that close public
hearing
[Music]
and now we have till 11 30.
could the could the chair please uh
come to the
as we said in the military assume the
position
at this time we are now going to open
the executive session on house bill 1433
relative to penalties for poisoning dogs
that's the penalties for poisoning dogs
one four
three three
is
does anyone wish to be recognized to
make any motion it's wide open for
anyone to do
oh wow
representative roy
yeah i'd like to make a motion of an
expedient to legislate
that has been seconded by representative
burke
does anyone wish to speak on the on the
motion representative rory
yes if um if i recall from the testimony
this um
the intent is obviously you know great
but the the there was confusion
about what constituted you know
intentional poisoning versus accidental
poisoning whose property the poison was
on it was it was very complicated um
and even speaking of law enforcement it
would be difficult to uh
to enforce as it was written
um we already have um felony uh animal
cruelty statutes
if it should become necessary to to
actually codify poisoning as part of
that
i think it needs to be done in a much
clearer fashion than than this bill
presented
so at this point um i'm going to move
and expedient to legislate
seeing no further hands raised we'll now
move the question if you're in support
of the
motion of inexpediting to legislate
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burke
yes
representative rhodes
representative greene
no
clerk votes yes
representative testament
representative true
yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
no we can't
we're in the voting mode please
representative sue newman
representative jack
yes
representative bordenay
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative bolden no
representative conley
yes
representative bradley
representative espitia
yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
17 yays two nays two not voting
i think
i think representative representative um
marty
representative martin jack is uh in for
um amy bradley right
or her i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry apologizing
correct you voted yes
very good
so it's 17 to 2 is the is the vote
move senate anyone yes i'm over consent
will there be a minority report
majority report
yeah i'll do
thank you representative roy
this time we'll now close the executive
session on
house bill one four
three
majority idl report
thank you
mushrooms mushrooms
where's david i think he walked down to
uh
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1349
decriminalizing
the possession and use of mushrooms
representative conley you used to be
recognized to make a motion of innix
being to legislate
yes mr chairman i would make that motion
this i understand i i appreciate the
comment i there is no list of what order
we're going in i kind of just look at
the clock and try to
gauge on what we can get done before the
next hearing so we don't have members of
the public waiting so
we'll uh we'll give a minute for
everyone to pull up
hb 13
and
who seconded the motion
representative rory
seconded
representative connolly do you wish to
speak
on the
motion of inx being to legislate
briefly
so i think like many people in the
committee i didn't have a great
background
or knowledge of
psilocybin mushrooms and it sounds like
there really are some true medicinal
benefits to this
that said
um i think we're not there yet i think
there's a lot of questions that
committee members might have and
especially in a state that hasn't yet
decriminalized or hasn't yet legalized
cannabis this might just be a tad too
far too soon
representative gareth recognized
thank you mr chair
um
for whatever reasons and i and maybe
didn't happen
i wrote on his study committee
was this supposed to go to study
committee
i'm just asking a question i i don't
know why i made that notation on my
sheet
so i'm just asking a question
there was a
an amendment that was floating around
obviously it's not but it was
my my understanding that amendment was
not germane
to the bill
and that amendment really was focusing
on more of the issue of medical
use
which
that's that's a separate subject
altogether that that policies are really
outside the purview of what we would do
here in criminal justice public safety
my my feeling on that
subject is that
in order for this committee to
do its due diligence in evaluating a
penalty
you would need to first master the
medical policy that you would put in
place
so i think we would be this
is my opinion
that it would need to pass the other
committee first and then come this
direction
considering it was a non-germane
amendment
the
other committee was free to take up that
issue at any time
on their own without any
comment or influence from this committee
so i thank you i i tend to agree that
this is really to decriminalize the
possession and
i think that's a conversation that we're
going to have in the state but
i think with cannabis moving forward
it might be too much too soon
and
i would say if we don't have a cannabis
policy in place at least you know
recreation this might i don't see this
making it very far i think it it's
raised enough awareness got us all
thinking but in this bill i think this
bill will be back
okay
thank you
representative muse
yes
i i i plan to support the itl motion
my preference would have been for
interim study
i feel that while there were some really
good objections raised by folks like the
state police
there was also a lot i learned at that
hearing about the potential therapeutic
use of uh
of this this
this particular chemical
and i would like to keep it on the
committee's radar with uh
with an interim study recommendation but
um
but lacking that i will support the itl
representative true
thank you mr chair um looking at page
two
around line
section d
are there any states that do give a
medical card for
suicidal
that that's what
that section is referring to
i'm not i'm not prepared to i couldn't
answer that
i don't recall any testimony to hearing
to that effect
seeing no uh for hands raised at this
time when i'll move the question
if you in support of the
motion of innix being to legislate
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burt
yes representative rhodes yes
representative greene
yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
representative true
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative sue newman
yes
representative jack yes
representative bourdain
yes
representative muse
representative ray newman yes
representative bolden
no
representative conley yes
representative bradley
representative espitia
yes
representative abbas
the chair votes yes
18-2
2-4
anyone mr move for consent
so moved will there be a minority report
you said too
okay
will anyone be doing a minority report
representative calling will you do the
honors of the majority
at this time we'll now close the
executive session
on house bill
now
so
mr chairman
representative burt i was just wondering
if you've heard anything about friday i
know it's a shocker but i think we're
going to get some snow in new hampshire
so and i have a subcommittee and i would
love to attend it but
i know they like canceling stuff
my understanding is that the all the
subcommittee hearings on friday will
will be canceled
thank you for telling me
so what i would recommend
for any of the subcommittee hearings the
next date we'll be here would be the
following wednesday
and uh we would if anything want to put
those on in the morning
and i would say any bills that we have
not held an exec on by the end of the
day today we should likely be
well i understand that
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on
it's at 11 the next hearing public
hearing is scheduled for 11 30. so we
have
well we i have three minutes but
this time when i open the executive
session on cacr 34 the use
the sale or cultivation of cannabis
representative testman do you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
second
that has been seconded by
representative roy
representative tusman do you wish to
speak speak to your motion
i can't hear them
i'm not sure we have a lot of other
agricultural things in the constitution
any any of the members wish to speak
representative muse
i intend to support the itl motion as
well as the itl motions for
the other cannabis constitutional
amendments
i don't feel that the use of cannabis
arises to a constitutional issue
i think our constitution is for more
more critical things
and
the regulation of cannabis
should be a matter for the legislature
to decide
and i don't think we need to put this
issue in front of the people
seeing no hands raised
excuse me representative true
only because i think it's time we stop
footing around on cannabis
i will support the constitutional
amendment the proposed constitutional
amendment
um let the people decide i don't see any
harm in that just
i i think there's there's probably
a lot of uh
opposed constitutional amendments having
to do with this
maybe that's too many for the people to
decide on
but
that's up for the people to decide if
they don't like the speed that the
legislature is moving at
thank you
seeing no hands raised at this time the
matter when i'll move the question if
you're in support of the motion of innix
being to legislate
please say
yes if you were opposed please say no
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch yes
representative bert
no representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
no
clerk votes no
representative testament yes
representative true
nay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
no representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
yes
representative jack yes
representative bordenay
yes representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative bolden
i'm sorry is the motion itl correct no
representative connolly yes
representative bradley
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
13 yays seven nays
one not
voting would it be a minority report
representative true
will they agree
representative green you wish to do the
minority report
would it be my journey a majority report
anyone
representative testimony you wish to do
the honors
thank you
but this time we'll now close the
executive session on cacr
34.
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on house bill 1145 relative to a
motor vehicle exception to criminal
restraint or false imprisonment
and relative to civil immunity and
physical force in defense of a person
and i believe that the sponsor of the
bill is unavailable so if there's any
if there's any member that would simply
just introduce the bill that no
testimony necessary
representative if you don't mind thank
you
the um
without spoiling the the potential
testimony i will say the sponsor of the
bill did send an email requesting that
this bill be uh in
inexpedient to legislate i just
thank you mr chairman and fine committee
members i am representative john burt
goffstown where in deering
i am opening house bill 1175
and if you could hold all questions to
somebody else oh 45 sorry let me correct
my eyes 11 45. thank you
thank you representative you are excused
the company now calls penny dean
oh
it should be red oh guess so
i'm used to the opposite so sorry
thank you my name is penny dean i'm an
attorney licensed in maine new hampshire
massachusetts
admitted to the federal courts d.c
circuit supreme court united states
supreme court and several other courts
and i see this as an anti-self defense
bill
basically the the one of the worst parts
of it is line 22 a
basically is trying to remove the
limited stand your ground protection new
hampshire has new hampshire truly
doesn't have stand your ground
protection it should have but it doesn't
but this
by or anywhere he or she has a right to
be by striking out that provision of 627
1a
and 20 7 4 3 a
basically removes tons of self-defense
protections that we do need we actually
need more in this state
and i respectfully would say that alone
should be enough to i tell it but it
sounds like we're already there i just
have seen bills flop and take different
procedural paths and i want to make sure
that this bill hopefully is dead on
arrival
there are many other provisions in it
that are
problematic and if you look at 6271a
which is found on line 12
of the first page
they want to remove protection of
premises and property pursuant to 6 27 7
and 6 27 8. i guess that means burglars
can come in your house and tear things
apart and maybe tear you apart and hey
you can just leave your house and let
them have at it
and i don't think that's where we want
to be
because anybody who is so crazy to break
in your house or come in your house
in addition to tearing your property up
your body may be next
and so i'm happy to answer mechanical
questions but here's the thing that the
committee has to know and this is
something that as a trial lawyer
frustrates me and just brings me to
tears actually
whether or not a trial judge will allow
an affirmative defense of self-defense
to be raised is totally up to the trial
judge
people think that you can raise it yeah
your lawyer can raise it you raise
emotion you bring up the facts but the
trial judge determines whether or not
that's actually going to be raised or
heard by the jury and to what level and
that's a really really big deal if
you're the one sitting in the
defendant's chair
the other issue is
whether or not
there's going to be any further
protections added because here's the
thing that you have to remember in this
state we do not elect judges and that's
a big deal trial judges in the majority
of states in this country are elected
which means you can unelect them when
they don't follow the constitution and
the laws
and so you have to think about that and
ask yourself
walk into a half a dozen courtrooms and
watch and ask yourself if you would want
to be tried with your freedom and life
online in front of a particular trial
judge and know they're there for life
pretty much until the 60s and i'm happy
to answer any practical questions of how
this works
i'm seeing no hands raised i want to
thank the witness for our testimony and
the witness is excused thank you do you
want me to undo the red button here okay
thank you attorney gene
are there any members of the public
present that wish to testify that have
not testified already
seeing no hands raised
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on house bill 1145
at this time we'll now
open the executive session on house bill
1145.
does anyone wish to be recognized to
make a motion of any speed to legislate
yes
representative burt you were recognized
with prejudice
thank you mr chairman i'll make a motion
to itl
second
that has been seconded by representative
harry gathered
representative bert you wish to speak to
your your motion
yes mr chairman
thank you
attorney dean when she spoke
said it exactly what i was going to say
you know just removes too much
to
for new hampshire
really any state
so the person has the right to defend
themselves if a burglar breaks into the
house
and uh that's it you know we need those
protections this bill would remove them
and that's why i support the itl and
made the motion
representative muse
while i'm peeved that the sponsor
declined to show up
i support the intent of the bill
because basically
i did not support the expansion of stand
your ground
in other sessions of this committee and
did not vote for it when it came up
before the legislature
this would unwind it and i support it
but i do not support the itl
thank you
representative harry gathering
um i just wanted to say that
i too like the bill but out of respect
for the sponsor and the letter that he
sent us
i am willing to itl
at this time
we'll now move the question
if you're in support of the motion of
innix being to legislate please say yes
if you're opposed
please say no the clerk will not call
the role
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt yes representative
rhodes yes representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative testerman
yes
representative true yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative sue newman
representative jack yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative bradley
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
with a vote of 19 to one the bill is itl
mr chairman i'll do a uh
majority report and i would like a
consent if we could get it thank you
representative burton thank you for
volunteering to do the majority report
will there be a minority report
and move mover consent representative
burt
yes please
thank you
this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill 1145
at this time the committee will be in
recess
to
the committee will be in recess till 1
1 pm
we're now
the community the criminal justice
public safety committee will come to
order
at this time
we will now open the executive session
on house bill
also known
as representative um
eric ethel we have now opened the
executive session on house bill 1108
we have been referring to it as the
purple paint bill i do not have a copy
of the villain in my binder
representative muse
well i believe representative harrick
gathway was going to make a motion of
any legislate
or representative burke yes
representative burt you have been
recognized to make a
thank you mr chairman and i make a
motion of itl and expedient to legislate
is there a second
that has been seconded by representative
harry gathering
representative burke do you wish to
speak to your motion of innex being to
legislate yes i would mr chairman and
thank you
mr chairman we heard testimony from
forest and lands new hampshire forest
and lands
new hampshire timber
associate lands association
new hampshire fish and game which all
oppose
this bill
they said uh they have tried it up in
maine and it has failed
you know matter of fact one person said
that it seems like there's more people
hunting on
the
partials that are painted purple
because people don't understand in this
area
the biggest thing you know to
what purple means
the biggest thing that
i'm opposed to this is new hampshire and
pretty much new england
is unique
we have it's called uh if i get the word
right common land
so you could own 500 acres or a thousand
acres or whatever it is
and your neighbors can just walk on it
now if you want to post it you can
but i kind of like the way it is
because
you know down south
in some of the states and i understand
also a little bit out west
you know some states it you know it's
pretty much it's not
everything is posted even without signs
so you have to get permission
where
you know this came from
you know when england we came over from
england and we started
moving around
this is just stuck for hundreds of years
that allow us to walk on somebody's
property that is not posted
you know without trespassing
and i think this bill would just cloud
up
the current situation we have which i
support and i hope you support the itl
and again you know there's three
uh major
landowners uh groups that um
you know oppose this
and i just see no value in this bill so
i hope you support the itl thank you
representative boarding
thank you chair i'm going to oppose the
ito motion
i think that the amendment that we have
not heard and uh
produces a hybrid
posting which would make it easier for
some of our land owners to
do
and maintain
um
so for that reason that reason alone i
consider it uh an advantage for uh
property owners that
want to post their land
i was not happy with part of the
amendment that was offered by
representative roy and that was because
of the penalty was a felony and i did
not like that but i think that this has
a
has merit
it would
allow posting of uh land in the current
way
but
not as
uh frequently as every 100 yards but
except for using purple paint and
the posting
of
of the day would be ever 250 yards
so i think that
this bill has a lot of merit and i'm not
going to support the itl
thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman i would like to
associate myself with the remarks my
good friend representative bordenay
um i i think that there is um my
constituents have who are landowners
i i represent deerfield nottingham
northwood
candia soon auburn
they own a lot of property there's some
of them are senior citizens and they
just see some merit and not having to to
either hire somebody or find a way to
get around their entire acreage every
year to replace damaged signs
and like i said my constituents have
asked for it and i am here for no other
reason than to represent them so i am
advocating for this bill to not be itl
so that another motion could be made
representative harry gathered
okay one of the um thank you um chair
one of the things that helped me with
this is
a document that we see from the division
of forests and lands
it was
patrick hackley director of new
hampshire division of forest land
and he says that the purple boundary
paint
to indicate no trespassing is an
uncommon practice in the northeast
and is not widely recognized recognized
by the majority of the landowners
foresters surveyors and forest
recreationists
posted signs are well recognized and can
be easily added or removed as landlord
owners desire
or ownership change as opposed to
essentially permanent paint markings
he also goes on to say that
there are well established time-tested
standards for boundary markings used by
licensed surveyors and foresters that
are more effective than those proposed
in this bill
so with that said i agree to the itl
representative conley
thank you mr chairman i'll be opposing
the itl
so traditions are important the
tradition of allowing anyone onto your
land unless it's posted that goes back a
long time
one thing i think is
one of many things that are that trump
tradition are property rights
property rights
so this is a the current tradition is a
diminishment of property rights it tells
a landowner they must do something incur
a cost
or anyone can access their property at
any time
this bill
purple
green orange whatever color
uh i would expect a hunter
to know
what that means if the law were to
change it's not onerous
and property owners should have choice
in how they mark their property thank
you
so
i'm just gonna
read from this
the iron needs a purple book but this is
what we have here i'll just explain that
in when you're dealing with criminal
trespassing
a person is guilty of criminal trespass
if
knowing that he is not licensed or
privileged to do so enters or remains in
any place
so knowingly a person acts knowingly
with respect to conduct or to the
circumstances that is
a material element
of an offense when he is aware that his
conduct is of such a nature or that such
circumstances exist
so in order to it's one thing to have
the purple paint uh essentially replace
the
no trespassing sign
the person would have to know what the
purple line of paint means
and
i said this earlier today
some of some of the members here
privately
that this is one of the few policies
that i believe the state would be better
served being one of the last states to
do it
because
the enforceability side
if a person does not know what that
means i mean
i don't think any of that defense would
work with us because we're all here on
the committee
but if you don't know what the purple
line means you can't prosecute you can't
enforce it and we heard that was a
problem in maine
and the way new hampshire's law is now
if your land doesn't say no trespassing
people
are
free to enter it for hunting for hunting
purposes now it's common practice that
you still
hunters will generally talk to the land
owner but
it's not a requirement
because i'm not aware of it being a
requirement so i'm just explaining that
for me
this is really an enforceability side
the policy itself is not the issue
and then
there's no restriction on the type of
paints you use there could be
environmental issues with that
this is things that things to think
about
and this will be back because like i
said i think new hampshire's better
serve being on the back end it's not the
front end
i don't see this being a huge problem in
the state that we're fixing or solving
by passing this
so frankly i'll be honest i would have
no idea if i did not sit on this
committee i would have no idea what the
purple painted tree meant
so
and that would that defense would
actually work because i'm not aware so
once someone explains it's different so
the other part of it is is
you can grant people access it it's kind
of hard to remove the purple paint where
the sign is easy to remove so there's
that problem too once it's on the tree
so i will be supporting the
motion of nxp to legislate and i
hope and welcome
my friends to join me
representative representative roy
thank you mr chairman um
i would just a couple quick points
as far as education it's a matter of
when you get your renew your hunting
license having a slip of paper that
explains the purple paint um
as we all know the ignorance of the law
is not an excuse to break the law
furthermore there'd be
enormous press coverage
it would be well known to the public but
having said that
also from an enforceability standpoint
many laws we change every year don't
um
don't necessarily make it to the the
public's at large view for a while i
mean if we took that that um tact with
every law we pass we might as well never
pass a law because nobody would know
about it so i i don't think that's a a
good argument against it
um
i think that the compromise um was good
i think it helps homeowners and again i
would reiterate my request that um the
itl fail thank you
thank you representative roy
thank you mr representative boardney
i just wanted to point out one thing
the purple painting doesn't mean
anything without the traditional posting
so if you take the po if you thought the
landowner decides that
hey
you know the hunters are okay
i don't mind people trespassing on my
property all he has to do is take down
the traditional posting because the
purple paint doesn't mean anything
without the traditional posting
so
i i think it's
is a great idea thank you
okay
can i ask though if you have the
traditional posting why do you need the
purple paint on top of that
uh is that a question for me yes
because it's easier to execute and you
don't have to to
execute it on an annual basis so it's
cheaper for the property owner to to
carry out and it's uh
easier
but what i'm saying is if you need the
purple paint
if you need purple paint and you have to
have the traditional posting by having
the traditional posting already
wouldn't the purple paint not be
necessary because it's already
traditionally posted okay
it's a question
as representative roy presented
the hybrid system is a traditional
posting
every 250 yards instead of every 100
yards it is
a lot less work but it is still work
now
posting with with a purple paint every
100 yards in addition to posting on
the traditional posting every
250 yards is is less of an issue a
problem
so i'm i'm going to maintain my position
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and ever since
we're i guess we're
leaning toward talking about the um well
i guess we are talking about the
amendment if this failed
um the amendment does not say
spray paint purple paint
or
a tres no trespass sign and or
you know so if the purple paint's there
it's still no trespass you can take your
signs down but it's still no trespass
because it doesn't specify
either or in my eyes
but then also
a second offense of
spray paint in a tree that is not yours
is a felony
i can't imagine anybody's going to vote
for a felony charge on a second
offense
when you go down in manchester and you
see all the buildings uh graffitied and
billboards are graffitied on the back
side of them in the fence you know the
big interstate fences they're graffitied
i don't think they get a felony for the
second third fourth time they get
stopped or get caught doing that so i
think the crime way more outweighs
you know the the uh the punishment
outweighs the crime you know is it wrong
to spray paint trees that aren't yours
yes but a felony charge
you know i just can't go for that so i'm
still sticking to my itl
well
traditionally when you recognize
something to speak you're supposed to
let someone who hasn't spoken already
yet that's why representative ray newman
issue
thank you i wasn't keeping adequate
track of who had spoken first
um
i
i want to say that i agree with my good
friend
john burt down there about
the felony uh crime i'm just not in
favor of that
and the other thing is that i'm finding
it difficult and i assume we are talking
about the amendment that was passed out
this morning and that's where it is and
there's no subsequent amendment
forthcoming so
i am confused by the wording in section
one on where they go and how they go and
how you put them out and that kind of
stuff so
i will vote yes for the itl
at this time
this time i will move the question if
you were in support of the motion of nxp
to legislate
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the rule
vice chairman roy
no
representative welch
yes
representative burt
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes no
representative testament
is that your final answer
representative pratt
no
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright yes
representative sue newman
no
representative jack yes
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative ray newman yes
representative bolden
representative conley
no
representative bradley
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
12 years seven days two not voting
mr chairman there will be a majority
report and um i doubt i can get it on
consent could i
will there be a minority report
by a vote of 12 years and seven days the
most banks being to legislate
passes
representative connolly you'll prepare
the minority report
this time we now close the executive
session on house bill
just just to give everyone a little road
map we're gonna now open the executive
session on house bill
1512.
but after this one the next two will
follow be cacr20 and ca
cr35 so just get those ready as well
so we now oh as we have now opened the
executive session on hb 512 that's
relative to the parole of certain
1512 excuse me
representative roy used to be recognized
to make a motion
i would um move itl on hp 15-12
is there a second
it has been seconded by representative
connolly
representative roy wishes
do you wish to speak to your motion
i i was actually going to but um
representative burt said that he wanted
to speak on it so i'm going to go ahead
and let him have it
representative you're recognized to
speak
thank you mr
chair
um
the
testimony we heard
um
just pointed out that this is not a good
bill
and i'm gonna live by those words and
vote for the itl
thank you representative bart
will the anyone else we speak
representative boardney
thank you mr chair
yes i'm going to oppose the i.t motion i
think that people in prison have
opportunity to to change their life
around 25 years is a long time and it is
possible for
prisoners to
become
new people
and um
i
think that they should get a chance to
have a parole review after 25 years or
even sooner but 25 years is plenty
thank you
and i'm just going to make a general
point it's it applies to this bill but
you look at lines 1 through 24.
although without even evaluating or
taking a position what those points made
those factual points and factual
statements have nothing to do with the
subject matter what the bill is trying
to accomplish
i would just
recommend
anyone putting bills in to not have a
necessary language like that because
they may you may lose support
on language like that
but ultimately i'm not sure how much
you'll gain
that's that's really the argument to
pass it not shouldn't be written in the
law
just just a thought but
but anyway
representative roy you wish to speak i
do thank you i i would agree with
representative bordenay in as much as i
i agree that um
that people incarcerated definitely
deserve a second shot in a review and 25
years is a long time however the sponsor
of this bill
did not coordinate in my opinion with
the
department of corrections with the
parole board
in such a way as to get them
their buy-in or at least their their or
their understanding what he was trying
to do with it
um
and we heard from the parole board we
heard from the department of corrections
it's a logistical nightmare waiting to
happen i think that legislation
accomplishing this end and maybe even
perhaps more is is far overdue but this
is not the vehicle for it um and
i'd be happy to co-sponsor with anybody
uh next session uh something that would
accomplish the similar with with the
buy-in and with the cooperation of the
all the stakeholders
but i can't support this bill as written
thank you
representative testerman
i've heard several bills regarding
parole
in in my time here
and
i just get the feeling
that
we we're not supporting the parole board
enough
we have rules that countermand each
other
they're understaffed
i'll go along with the ito because i
think we need to do something about the
parole board in particular i think
they're working hard but i
i don't think it's doing a service to
the citizens of this of this state
regardless of what it does for the
prisoners
seeing seeing no hands raise it at this
time when i move the question if you in
support of the motion of innix being to
legislate please say
yes if you're opposed please say no
the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
representative burt yes
representative rhodes yes representative
greene
yes
clark votes yes representative testament
representative true yes representative
pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
no
representative jack no
representative bourdain no
representative muse
no
representative bolden
oh excuse me representative ray newman
no
representative bolden i'm sorry can you
remind me of the motion is it itl itl no
representative conley yes
representative bradley representative
espitia no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
12 years eight nays one not voting
by a vote of 12 yes yeas eight
mays the most of innings being legislate
passes we had it was not the exact same
but we had a similar
bill last year
that we made a similar recommendation on
however
we didn't it was been refiled it was not
itled on the
in the by the house as a whole we had
the same bill last term as well
before this committee as well yes
will it be a minority report
representative herrick gathering will be
doing
the minority report
this time when i'll close the executive
session on house bill
15 12.
at this time when i'll open the
executive session on
cacr20
yes
this is
relating to personal liberty that adults
shall have the right to possess cannabis
for personal consumption
uh
representative testerman
do you wish to be recognized to make a
motion
wait a minute
what
who are you not quite ken
no we are currently in executive session
for cacr 20.
and and representative while i assure
you i did not park in your parking space
today
that is that is the goal
representative testament do you wish to
be recognized to make a motion
i'll make the i make a motion of itl
because we've got too many of these
cannabis bills
in the works right now and
we need to have only one
and see see what happens with that
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
um
my opposition to this bill uh more has
more to do with the um the
did represent roy did you second
the motion
yeah sure
all right
so that's that's what's just
i think
all right let me let me correct myself
right the motion was made of the next
being to legislate by representative
testament representative roy do you wish
the second that motion yes okay okay my
apologies everybody may continue
no problem thank you
it's my opposition is more related to
the fact that again it's a cacr
um i i
agree with what representative mew said
earlier that that
constitutional amendments are much more
serious and far-reaching
than
especially within simple you know
agriculture issues specific plants i
don't believe belong in the constitution
i also agree with representative true
that the people should decide
having said that um
we can't put every single thing in front
of the people to decide um that's why
they sent us here as kind of goalies to
screen some of this stuff
and um i think we do have several bills
in front of the house and some in the
senate dealing with the same subject and
i just don't think that the opening the
uh
the constitution is a place for this so
i uh support the idea
representative conley
thank you mr chairman
i agree
generally with what representative muse
said with the last cacr as well although
that one had problems that i won't get
into but
um
we have bills before the house
they're going through the process and we
know that process tends to run into
hurdles in the other chamber
we don't know what's going to happen
with this bill but if we are going to
bring a cacr forward
i would recommend this as the simplest
one
this would
this was written by the democratic
leader the former chair of this
committee
it's extremely simple in its purpose and
it would provide
this
legislature in the next term
with a clear mandate to get this passed
doesn't stipulate how it would come
forward
it would still come before the
legislature
and
given the track record of the other body
of
uh to borrow a phrase playing goalie on
um cannabis bills i think that this
would be something that we could get
before the people get it on the record
and get this chamber
to finally move forward with some action
representative burt
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i will
be supporting the itl of this bill i
believe in letting the voters have
the option and we've already done that
with cacr34
i did vote against the
itl i believe it was itl on that motion
but this motion i will support
because we already gave them an option
on the cacr34
just
to clarify what this would do it all
adults shall have the right to possess
cannabis intended for their personal
consumption
now
on the way as written
whether you support recreation or not
you can have 200 pounds
as long as it's intended
for personal consumption
this would basically
it's yes it's very simply written but it
would basically
bar virtually any type of regulation for
it at least the way i read it
this is something that will be subject
to court interpretation now i could be
wrong
people may not agree with that
but all adults have a right to possess
cannabis intended for their personal
consumption with i don't see there's any
room for any
capacity limit or possession limits on
that
whether it's growing
i mean you wouldn't need
ph thc levels i mean even if you did
make a
personal consumption of
people different individuals have
take different amounts to have different
effects
it's it seems just how do you
then how do you establish the the intent
i mean you can sometimes
use a large quantity possession with
intent to distribute i get that
but
it seems to me that just this is going
to be something that will be drawn out
in the course for a while
for better for worse
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman just
article 2a doesn't have any kind of
restriction on how many firearms or how
much ammunition an individual can
possess
and it's for personal consumption is it
not
well
article 2a is the right to bear arms to
protect yourself
your family your property and your state
so it's describing what you're bearing
arms to do i'm just saying this is and
it does not mention how many you may or
may not possess or what type or what
power does it
no and there is and there is no
restriction on on that so you can own as
many
firearms as you wish and i my point is
that this would also apply to camps in
the same way
for better for worse i'm not
just as it's written that's how i would
read it
and it would make regulating very
difficult
which which that may be accurate
representative harry gathered thank you
mr chair um
when i look at this and it says adults
i'm assuming
that is 18 years and older
i'm going to say to the committee let's
not forget what effect
cannabis has had on the younger
generation particularly those between
the age of 18 and say 25 and how many of
them have ended in the mental ward
because of cannabis
so i really think when we're talking
about this that we really need to be
very clear
about the age limits that would want to
do cannabis with or say that it's legal
to do
that's my spell
representative true
thank you mr chair and i'll be brief
because i don't want to bogot anyone's
important time
but uh
see uh one we just
voted on ca cr34 that itld so the people
aren't going to have a vote on that
this one is a simple possession
um
i don't understand the the worries about
maybe you have two ounces or two pounds
uh there's no limitation on how much
alcohol i can have in my house
um
again this is just the
let the people say what they want that
if the if the
anecdotal
tales that we have that the vast
majority of the people are in favor of
legalization let's give them the vote
maybe they're not happy with the fact
that we're still dragging this issue out
that's why i cannot support the
do not support the itl thank you
if i can inquire in about
the cacr
with in respect to hp 1598 we we just
passed in the house
by vote 235 to 119
ought to pass as amended
this cacr
arguably would conflict with even that
legislation
i'm just pointing that out
it
in my opinion it would i just don't
that's that's just why i read it
representative true you may resp
you have an excited look and you're i'm
curious um
no if if we legalize cannabis
we can't have any laws that conflict
it's just it's legalized and it wouldn't
be we doing it it would be the people
doing it
correct
we're representing the people now
representative roy
thank you
thank you i just want to make one more
point with
the the blanket legalization argument
is that if
anyone of a certain age remembers the
difference between cannabis today and
cannabis say in the 1980s or 70s
what is going to happen with the genetic
engineering of these plants in the
future going forward we have no idea
cannabis could be infused with with
opium or bread with something else and
it would still fall into this i i feel
like again making a blanket it's okay
it's opening pandora's box we don't know
what's going to happen and furthermore
this is still federally illegal
and if we you want to bring attention
you know the feds have so far been
staying at arm's length when states do
these things
well the first state that's going to go
ahead and say well we have no regulation
whatsoever come to new hampshire and you
can have all the part you want is going
to draw federal attention
um and every single person who has this
is going to be
prohibited from owning a firearm
there's all kind of implications so it'd
be great we put in our constitution we
can have part no problems well
every single person who uses it is in
violation of federal law regardless of
what our constitution says so
i just think that's important to know
representative muse
i just wanted to say that i have spoken
in favor of cannabis legalization
on the house floor multiple times
and i will do so again as long as it
takes
but i do not think that a constitutional
amendment is the right venue to take
to make this happen
when i look at our bill of rights i see
natural rights equality of men the right
of privacy
rights of conscience
i just don't think that cannabis
is at that same level
and uh i think the best way to approach
this is through the legislation uh that
we have let's pass it let's convince the
senate to go agree with it and get the
governor to sign it and cannabis
legalization will happen in new
hampshire
thank you
representative testerman
i think i heard something a few minutes
ago
representative roy did you say that
if we legalize cannabis in this state
that those people who are using it
cannot own an owner a firearm
oh that's what i thought
i i believe if they regularly regularly
use it
no it says a user
the courts have interpreted that as a
regular user i think it says ninth
circuit though that's not our circuit
but anyway we don't need to get into it
we'll talk about that later
we'll talk in the office after
at this time the
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman and just a
if you haven't heard
senator schumer out of new york has
actually asked a group of other senators
and u.s congressmen to put their heads
together to duplicate what's going on in
the states that have moved forward with
the legalization process so although
presently that is a uh there's sound
basis in that the
the federal prohibition um is not long
for this country at this point time i
would have to say
amen to that
at this time when i'll move the question
if you are in support of the motion of
innix being to legislate please say yay
if you are opposed please say
nay the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burt yes
representative rhodes yes
greene yes
clerk votes no
representative testament yes
representative true nay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
yes
representative jack yes
representative bordenay
yes
representative muse
representative ray newman
no
representative bolden
yes
representative conley no
representative bradley
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
15 yays five nays one not voting
the motion of innix being to legislate
passes will there be a minority report
bradley's not present
representative testament would you be
another
another majority report
no
they are very similar
you probably only have to change some
minor words from
thank you representative testament
at this time we'll now close the
executive executive session on ca cacr20
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on
house bill
1072 establishing a criminal penalty for
denying an elected school district
official access to any school district
facilities documents or events all right
this time we recognize representative
weiler to introduce hb
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee representative ken weiler
rockingham 13 the towns of kingston and
hampstead
i'm personally acquainted with two
incidents of a school board chair and a
superintendent who overstepped their
authority by denying the two people one
a document and the other access to
school buildings we need for there to be
consequences for these abuses or they
will just continue
it was expensive and a lengthy process
for the person denied the document to go
to court to prevail
a threat of misdemeanor might have
produced the document sooner
in the case of being denied access to
school property the superintendent made
up a charge of endangerment when the
member contradicted his presumption that
going outside to a portable classroom
puts students in danger the members said
i was trained as a sniper if i wanted to
harm children it would be while they
were on the playground
superintendent overreacted was and
accused the member of dangerous and
inflammatory statements and issued a ban
on him being on school property so
happens that the school property is
where we go to vote
was he denying him of his vote
i've heard of other instances of
high-handedness of people whose
positions went to their head and they
took upon themselves powers that they
did not possess
in most cases the abuser had a conflict
with the opinions of the abused party
and was seeking some sort of revenge
purpose of this bill is to keep
discussions civil
so that no one tries some action that is
inappropriate
this threat of misdemeanor will be
seldom used but should serve as a
reminder that disagreements on policy
should be resolved by a motion and a
vote not vindictiveness please support
this proposal happy to answer any
questions thank you
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so my understanding
is that an elected school for school
board official
is elected for policies and financials
of the district so how would you propose
if a school board member chooses that
they want to see documents such as the
benefits that a school employee has
chosen
or an iep of a student
or any other the confidential
information because it says here
shall not be denied access to any school
facilities documents so how would you
propose
excluding the documents
if it was relevant to decisions they
were going to make
about finances and and staffing and so
on you know they may not be able to have
it in a form that they could pass out to
someone else but they should be able to
view it
thank you mr chairman
are you aware that in that a student's
iep is absolutely absolutely
confidential information and no school
board member at any time has access to
see that
they may be looking at the costs and and
have things redacted that then that are
confidential but there should be an
overall idea of what are we spending on
special ed how many students are
involved and
what's the most expensive and so on and
quite often we hear about two hundred
thousand dollars being spent on special
ed well everybody's going to figure out
who it is
and wonder if there's some other
alternative and have they have people
looked into the alternative so there's
there's things that they may need to
know that could be redacted as far as
identifying a specific student and i
know when when we talk about the hipaa
and
i've gone to uh when we're doing
education and finance and we say you
know we need to know
how many uh students of this and that
and their their claim is well we can't
give it to you because you would figure
out which student it is and that would
that would uh
betray confidential information so
you know there are some parts of it that
can be revealed
without
and and i'm sure that they could use
that that argument but once it's
redacted and
the gist of the information could be
there for them to make policy decisions
representative testerman
thank you and uh thank you for answering
my question are you aware of the
question
uh
how do you how do we audit you who
audits you
you know are these properly identified
and the answer was well we can't be
audited
so
wouldn't i need access to some of these
kinds of documents to determine if if
we're our
special ed people are doing their job
correctly
i would hope that would be the case
because there's a lot of this under
hipaa and and confidentiality that a lot
of information is withheld not only from
the public but for the people on the on
the policy making things so i think that
some of these things need to be
re-examined just
an hour or so ago we were meeting on
legislative performance audit and
oversight committee and we were calling
for
an uh an audit of this special ed
and we went over several of the things
and many of us had been involved in
other committees previously on special
ed spending
and we're going to wait for another
scoping statement to come back from from
the the audit division on looking at
these sort of things and it'll be
interesting how much of this
stonewalling we get but we're looking at
it from a
kind of a high level
place and and
what i do know and they had not done a
special ed
audit since 1999
which is highly unusual that it goes
that long so
in the interim you and i have seen
huge increases in staffing
which they're building their own empire
under this
guise of we can't we can't expose this
so
we may have later legislation to say you
know within a certain realm of
policymakers yes this can be exposed but
they would have to take an oath not to
reveal it
representative espidia
i just want to thank you mr church you
want to follow up with your with your
statement that you just made so
you believe that they're building an
empire under the sun for
oh sorry for
for special education
some of the most vulnerable students
that we have
okay
yes and we also discussed within that
other committee
what have been the results
from the millions of dollars that all
our
taxpayers are paying and yet we have
people that get handed a diploma who
can't read
so why wasn't that taken care of so
there's lots of failures in this this
whole system that i think that everybody
needs to get a look at and we're going
to have an audit and it's going to give
us some
some further
leading and where to go thank you
representative thank you for your
testimony and the chair will inquire
with a question and thank you for taking
my question
when an iep's put together for a student
it's would you done in some team meeting
setting where there's
several i don't want to say i don't
stakeholders right term but there'll be
several people at the table putting it
together
where the education plan is targeted for
that individual student
so i suppose if you did audit it
i
i guess my question is how wouldn't the
numbers con constantly change based on
how the iep evolves as the child
progresses through school or once the
child graduates those numbers would be
stale
granted it's a snapshot of given time
and place
but
nevertheless
what did you spend this last
year
on
how many different students and we just
looked at i think there was a list of 15
different categories that they could be
put in
and
you know multiple things obviously
blindness and deafness are fairly
apparent but then there's also you know
a bunch of other things nervousness and
anxiety and all these things that um
you know it
in some cases when i visited charter
schools they had students they had they
pointed out to me they had three
students that came there with
special ed for anxiety
once they were in the charter school
the anxiety went away
so
you know sometimes these things need to
be reassessed on a regular basis so
representative bolden
thanks for taking my question um
i was wondering
[Music]
the way that it looks like the way that
this bill is structured
you want to guarantee access
to facility records and staff
with the exception of people who are
either being investigated for have been
convicted of certain crimes
[Music]
notwithstanding the fact that there are
definitely lawmakers in new hampshire
who've been convicted of crimes but are
not necessarily a threat at the time
that they're elected
[Music]
is there a reason that you excluded
um because i i looked at the list uh
under rsa 189 colon 13-a i looked at the
list of
violation violations
uh in the in the rsas and there's a
reason that you decided to exclude 644
that's the harassment
rsa and i and i would imagine that like
someone who's
maybe become
troublesome for school staff who needs
to be removed from the property
harassment would be a basis for i like i
think i feel like that's plausible
especially with the things going on in
nashua
um
and i'm wondering
if there was an intent to exclude that
thanks for taking my question as
discombobulated as it was
if someone has been charged for a crime
and they
and they have been elected to the school
board
and
they would want to grab everything they
couldn't sometimes be problematic just
don't make make trouble for everybody
and
so the idea is you're under
investigation all of a sudden we get a
the court and the attorneys are closing
the amount of
stuff you can get and obviously you'd
probably at some point be removed from
the board while this is pending so
that person could couldn't come back and
ask her everything under the sun
just to kind of tie up things in court
by presenting this and this and this
representative bouldin you recognize for
a follow-up
sorry i just want to take one stab at
clarifying my discombobulated question
it appears that this legislation
would guarantee access to a school
facility by a person who's maybe been
engaging in harassment against the
school or students in the school
staff at the school something along
those lines and i could see that it's
being plausible given the current
environment in politics and so i was
wondering if that was
um if you're aware of that and if it was
um intentional if you feel like that's
less of a risk um
thanks for letting me take another stab
at it well it's very specific you have
to be elected to the school board to
request these documents
and then the people that elected you are
going to expect you to serve them and
not your own purposes
to get
policy making and
budgets done
so
it's kind of narrow it and
you know they would
if it was somebody that's going to
harass
usually they would have been harassing
before they became a candidate and
everyone would be aware of it and
wouldn't they wouldn't be elected
that's usually what i've seen happen
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
i'm envisioning this
like if i went
and requested a police report they're
going to redact certain information so
i'm assuming
that the school board member is not
going to want to know that little tommy
lives at seven bay street
and sally lives at uh mammoth road you
know some number uh it's it's it's just
the overall
how much is it costing
this is the students
these are the staff right you know it's
kind of an overview it's it's not
personal information that the member
would be after
no that's not the intent thank you
representative newman thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um as i look at the words access to any
school facilities are there any
limitations
or is any
elected official have access to the
school to go anytime anywhere in the
school
are there any limitations
i don't think that's the intent but
the the thing i'm responding to was this
as as i say in in
number three um saying you know this is
a foolish thing saying kids can't walk
outside to go to the classroom because
if somebody wanted to
hurt them they'd be a sniper oh that's
such a terrible statement you can't go
anywhere near school property i mean
i don't think i think that was
overstepping the authority of that
superintendent
follow-up
representative newman recognized for a
thank you and i i
i don't support doing uh you know
supporting or turning down legislation
on anecdotal information so i
i just think that there's too many
things that
i'll i'll put a question um
do you think the
principal of the school
will be able to control the safety of
his school if he if
any elected official has access to the
school for any reason at any time to do
anything
no i think that's understood when they
when they go on the school board that
it's there's a certain limit to where
how they will behave and
you know unless they're invited into the
school and asked to sit in a class or
make a presentation they're not expected
to be there but to say you know it's
we forbid you to go to any school
ground
i don't know maybe it needs a little
more tweaking but that's the intent
representative sue newman
yes thank you and thank you for taking
this question you brought up
special needs and ieps
in the work that you have done so far
have you become aware that in
some school districts maybe
a lot of them
that there are parents who don't feel
their children's ieps are being met
because the school districts are
there's always a budget situation there
so have you
talked about that at all thank you yeah
that's that's one of the things we we
talked about having the audit to
determine that sort of thing because it
looks like we're spending a lot of money
for very little return so
yes and and
um the chairman of the performance audit
oversight committee had just been on a a
lengthy
study committee that had found so many
complaints from the parents and we're
trying to find a way to to fix them and
we're hoping the audit will give us some
clues what we can include in legislation
thank you for the question it's a
continuing thing
representative uh thank you mr chairman
uh thank you representative weiler for
appearing uh can you help me understand
where in line five uh regarding
documents it creates an expectation that
those documents are going to be redacted
somehow to remove personal information
i guess it would be easy enough for the
people to present the document to say
here's the document you requested i am
required to redact this by this law
and the person would just have to accept
that because
the person giving you the document can
can't disobey a
law representative the chairman inquired
with the question
if this if this bill were to become law
and
a member of the budget committee were to
obtain documents from a school regarding
a
a student's iep
i understand it's it's part of an audit
but
what exactly would be the goal to
accomplish what's the goal of
accomplishment looking at the iep
in determining whether are you trying to
figure out what the iep was
appropriate for that student i'm just
trying to figure out what would you do
with those documents
we've spent a hundred thousand for this
student to it to be
counseled by such and such a person
what are the results
is there a behavioral change
um have they learned to read have they
learned to write
show me show me the progress
on this very expensive student that
we've had for
for a number of years i think that's a
legitimate question
thank you representative
representative testament
thank you thank you for taking my
question
are you aware that
there is an identifier number
assigned to each
yes special ed student
and
that even
when karen and i took them to court to
get that data
a list of
by identifier numbers and how much they
had spent
we went to the supreme court it is not
allowed even though that was a
you know so
how are you going to get around those
the information
say that again the supreme court is was
not allowing you to know what that
identifier referred to
the supreme court
said because we we wanted to look and
see if the numbers
in ours town were where the same numbers
may be showing up somewhere else where
was there double charging going on
and
and we were we were the supreme court
after you know a couple other courts
said you can't have that data
even though they're
i mean it is
do you remember you remember the reason
why you couldn't have it i have to go
back anyway
okay
i guess there's other parts of the law
that needs to be changed so we're
looking forward to this audit that we're
going to get back it might take a year
to get some of the information but
i think a lot of us have been stymied by
the special ed costs and
and the secrecy that's there that
you don't even know why
ex-students been under special ed for 10
years and it hasn't done any good
just to follow up
are you aware that eventually
these things are all federally
enforceable ieps become federally
enforceable that eventually the
special ed department will become
head of the school
it seems like that's the progress
they'll come to the school board and say
either pay up or go to jail yeah we had
a we had some data we looked at 29 000
plus students are special ed coded out
of 160 000 so it's
it's getting to be a bigger percentage i
think we're one of the larger
percentages in the country
for coding
so i definitely think this is an area we
should all be concerned with thank you
hoping i can make a two o'clock meeting
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman um thank you for
taking my question i you had mentioned
hipaa several times in your testimony
and i just want to
um see
if you're aware that schools actually
don't follow under hipaa they actually
follow under ferpa and under ferpa
even redacted names are still protected
we we had that question uh some years
ago in finance when we're looking
into
um
some of the spending that was going on
and that was that was the word that the
department of ed used that's why i used
it
because we knew that 20 million was
being spent on some students we asked to
know
can we find out
by school district or by no you can't
find out by student can we find out by
school district where this this money is
going if somebody had a medical problem
i can't remember the
classification but some money could come
not only from the the school district
but from this federal
uh
medicaid
okay
now we have a formula for special ed so
you have to spend
three and a half times the average cost
per pupil
within the school district's budget
before you that can then ask for
what we used to call catastrophic aid to
come from the state
and then the state's going to pay 80
until you get to 10 times the average
cost per student
and
so what are you including
in this three and a half times
and you could be including
money that
wasn't really coming from the school
district although that's the intent you
could be including money that came from
medicaid you could be including federal
money
and you're just kind of hiding it all
under this is how much got spent before
we ask
for things so that those are things that
i get a little frustrated
why we're having to take this money out
of the catastrophic aid fund which isn't
called that anymore and and uh
because you claim you spent three and a
half times and perhaps it wasn't all
district money
so those are those are the frustrations
that arise when you're trying to find
out information
representative conley
thank you
i don't see anything in this bill about
much of anything that's been discussed
during this
session
but it sounds like there's a
deep-seated
um
just i wouldn't say opposition but
i guess is the goal of this to uh
restrict access
to services for students in special ed
is that what you're really after here
that's that's the side that kind of gets
sidetracked
but what i'm what i'm trying to say is
there are people that sit on a school
board and because they don't happen to
agree with the majority and say wait i
want a copy of that document no you
can't have it
for what reason can't i just said you
couldn't
or this thing like i talked about where
the superintendent forbids a member of
the school board from being on any
school property i don't think that's
within his authority
so i'm trying to take care of those
situations we got sidetracked on special
ed because of all the walls that are
there but i'll be back later when we get
the audit and find out what we what we
in fact can find out thank you
all right seeing no hands raised thank
you representative for your testimony
thank you for your thorough discussion
good luck with the 2 o'clock
the committee now calls brian hawkins
from neanh
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record brian hawkins
here today representing nea new
hampshire we represent
uh school uh staff across the state um
17 000 members and um here today in
opposition of house bill 1072
and i'll focus my uh testimony really on
um the
the
line five and this is uh relative to the
uh
school district facilities documents or
school events um specifically our
concern
about
one of our concerns about this bill
would be
the lack of definition of what a school
document would be so does that and i
think this was raised with one of the
questions already does that include
personnel files
medical records tax information the
students grades
it's already been brought up about
certain privacy laws
and
you know as as i read this um it you
know it does not
um preclude any of those uh things it
just says um documents
and so uh we think that the bill is is
far too broad
and if they're
and
we would ask you to find it an expedient
to legislate and i'll conclude my
testimony right there thank you
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um i see you're opposed to it you cited
some reasons um i would expect you'd
like to help us get to the bottom of
this and make sure that we're getting
uh return our investment that we're
making into the school boards would you
provide some suggestions on how you
could improve this with great
specificity so that we can move forward
instead of just asking for it to be
killed right out of the gate
well i i guess from the the testimony of
the sponsor and the discussion that i
heard i was actually struggling to
figure out what it is the sponsor was
trying to do and so
we would be happy to work with the
committee in any capacity that they
asked to to uh
but
i would i would first want to have some
greater clarity in in terms of what the
sponsor
i think is representative pearson as the
prime sponsor uh is seeking to
accomplish so i'm and
i see him in edna all the time i'm happy
to ask him that question too
recognize for a follow-up yes and can
you speak to the um the apparent fact
that new hampshire has a higher
percentage of students that have been
identified with an iep or in some type
of special education program and could
you speak to why what you what your
opinion might be as to the cause of that
um i i will confess representative i am
not an expert on a special education
um
or uh
on the iep process
um i would say that if you if you do
have questions about that we there is a
there is an organization that deals with
this a special education administrators
association i know that they're very
knowledgeable on the subject
but i i wouldn't pretend to to to give
you an answer to that question
um
uh because as i said i you know i'm not
an expert on that
thank
you
thank you for your testimony if the
chair may inquire with the question
so if an iep
for a student exceeds
a hundred thousand dollars
what is the
issue with the member of the budget
committee whose
job is to hopefully balance a budget
to investigate whether that that money
is being allocated in a responsible
manner
uh i mean i i'm not aware of
a reason why
a budget committee member cannot ask
that of an administration of
statistics and and so forth so
uh i mean our op as i said our
opposition of the bill has more to do
with the way it is written and and the
broadness with which it has been uh
as i said the broadness with it which it
has been um
written so
and
i'll follow up that question and thank
you for taking my question
some ieps they can be 30 40 50 pages you
know as a
four or five something summary
although may
it's a summary it may not necessarily i
think what i understood the testimony
from the
representative introduced the bill was
they wanted to see if the student was
making progress and that's not
necessarily a negative reflection on the
iep
but if this district spending over a
hundred thousand dollars a year
i guess what is the concern with with
having
some
someone evaluate whether that that's
money's being used you know in a
responsible manner on behalf of the
taxpayer
what's the opposition to that i don't
have any opposition to
a school board member or a
budget committee member asking questions
about the performance of their school
about the performance of the programs
that they have in their school
what what i'm here saying to you
is that
this goes well beyond that
and
and for you to pass this uh into law i
think is going well beyond maybe
um
when we get to the bottom of this is
what what the what the actual
intent
of the of the bill is so uh all i have
is
the bill that was
uh issued to the public and and put
forward for a public hearing and so
um
so i i
not sure there's much more i can tell
you beyond that uh mr chairman
representative boardney
chair thank you for taking my question
uh since i'm not on the education
committee i really don't understand the
workings of uh
of what is all going on as far as budget
but
representative wilder brought up
uh a problem with audits now
what are are our school
uh
budgets audited on an annual basis or
what what is the basis for audits for
uh school expenses sure uh if
if
i would be happy to to get back to you
with that i would also say i think
following me is uh
represented from the school boards
association who might have a little bit
more insight in terms of into the the
the budgetary and audit questions
all right thank you
sue newman
yes thank you
mr hawkins do you have any thoughts on
um
on what would be in these times i'll say
over the last 10
10 years or
to currently
on what would be
problematic with a
an elected board member just going on to
or trying to go out into or onto a
school property
almost at any time that they think is a
right thing to do and that would be
for um building
personnel including teachers if you have
any thoughts on that
i guess that goes back to some of the
the clarity of
or lack of definition in in the bill so
what does
what would count as a school event
um you know does that mean
um a football game
or does that mean
um
you know
a vaccine clinic that's happening i i
don't know what the school event is as
it's defined in this bill and i don't
want to bring in that issue into
this discussion but uh i in in in
sitting to answer to try and answer your
question um i think that's one of our
major uh concerns with the bill is the
lack of definition
all right thank you
representative testament
begin with you're going to yell at me
because it's not really a question
schools are audited every year
and but they're just on
dollars and cents
what i believe right
representative testament
you just you basically gaveled yourself
before i could
with
you'll have you'll have time to make
open ended statements or general
whatever statements you want during the
executive session i assure you of that
and
with respect to the witness you don't
need to respond to
the stable i appreciate the committee's
time thank you
thank you for your testimony
we now call barrett christina from the
new hampshire school boards association
thank you mr chair and thank you members
of the committee for the record my name
is barrett christina i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire school
boards association
i'm not in front of this committee often
if ever
so just by way of background we are a
private nonprofit organization we
represent approximately 161 school
boards across the state providing a
variety of services training assistants
things of that nature and also
legislative advocacy so we are opposed
to house bill 1072 for a number of the
reasons that have already been stated
and some of the questions that have
already been uh presented
from this committee
primarily when we're talking to focus on
the documents aspect first and
unfettered access to to documents within
the school district
as has already been mentioned
you know nhsba would have significant
concerns if a school board member had
unfettered access to a student record
i know a lot of the conversation
was about special education i'll tell
you right now anything relative to
special education is deemed confidential
under both state and federal law
department of education rule 1119
confidentiality requirements there's a
whole section in state rules from the
department of education they're already
talking about the confidentiality of
of of special education records further
and more expansive than that nhsba
argues that anything within a student
record is absolutely not fit for
anybody's consumption a board member
you know teachers administrators special
education staff on sort of a need to
know basis if you will to help provide
education services to that child
certainly they would have access to
records within that student file
but student records just you know as a
blank statement should be locked up
the second aspect relative to employee
files
you know nhsba is often advocated that
if push came to shove if a school board
which i think is another interesting
aspect this talks about a school board
member
school boards operate as a collective
entity if you look at the department of
the rules of new hampshire the statutes
that deal with
all the statutes impacting school
districts they're 1500 pages long
it talks collectively the board the
board the board there are a couple
provisions in their right to know law
that give authority to a chairperson for
example to call a special special
meeting of a public body or an emergency
meeting of a public body but in the
educational context the board has to
operate as a collective entity as a
as a as a a single body if you will
there's nothing in law that gives
individual rights to individual school
board members i think that's important
to note as well too
but so relative to the employee
the employee files um you know if if an
employee is before the school board for
a hearing whether or not that's a
non-renewal a termination a disciplinary
hearing
the pertinent documents will be
presented at that hearing the
evaluations
um the employee reviews but there's
other personal confidential information
that may be within an employee personnel
file perhaps they had to take disability
leave perhaps they're on some sort of
plan where they need accommodations um
within their within their workplace
other medical information if you will
maybe in in an employee's personnel file
that should be confidential as well too
relative to the access to facilities i
guess my first question would be for
what purpose is that individual school
board member
coming to the school
and asking to be to to to enter the
school
you know we have some sample policies
and we would advise the school board you
know the school board member if you
would like to view the school talk to
the superintendent talk to the principal
and make an appointment rather than just
just showing up um you know is it too
you know is it to to to just to observe
you know we can't have
people just kind of coming coming in and
out of a school building and walking in
and out of in and out of classrooms
where there may be confidential
information going on or or observing
students or things of that nature but
you know are they coming in to make sure
that the
maintenance guy fixed the boiler or put
the windows in the right way you know
there needs to be some sort of purpose
behind this so you know unfettered
access to the facilities i know maybe
make a phone call and talk to your
superintendent rebuilding principal and
say i'd like to come down and see how
the the the maintenance project is
coming along i'd like to come down and
and see how the new gymnasium is coming
along some things of that nature so um
relative to some of the special
education concerns that were that were
that were being talked about and
discussed you know the money is one
thing but the how and the why a student
is getting services and who's providing
them um that's between the parents and
and the school district staff of whether
or not the kid is making significant
educational progress under the iep
you know
could a school board or a budget
committee in the aggregate get how much
money are we spending on special
education yes could they get numbers in
the aggregate how many paraprofessionals
are we have on staff that are providing
special education services
yes um but asking how much of this
placement cost for this particular kid
and how many paraprofessionals and aides
for this particular kid in our opinion
would would be touching on the
confidentiality aspect that you're not
allowed that you're not allowed to
breach
last
and i'll conclude my testimony there was
some discussion i think among this
committee and among
representative weiler about redacting
some of the particular records
i just want to let you know that there's
nothing in law the right to know law
about redacting documents it's a
judicial creation
we all live with it we all do that as
needed a request comes in under the
right to no law it's passed off to a
school district attorney they go through
make recommendations as to what can be
redacted and what should be made public
but i just want to let you know there's
nothing in law that speaks to redaction
of documents it's a judicial creation
that public bodies have sort of adapted
to and adjusted to over the last i want
to think that was in
1989 when the court created that
standard on their right to no law so um
with that we um we we oppose the bill we
think it's way too broad we think that
school boards would be setting
themselves up for liability if they gave
unfettered access to some of these
records and with that i'm pretty happy
to answer any questions the committee
may have
thank you for your testimony and if the
chair would like to inquire with a
question and thank you for taking my
question
if a member of the school board is
elected by
by the people
what why is there a concern whether a
member of the school board
would
show up at a public school to observe
how the school's operating so i mean
they have to state their reason for
being it doesn't seem
i'm just wondering what is the concern
with that
thank you for the question
representative um well when we have
students within the facility
um there is private confidential
information occurring or private
confidential events happening within a
school district i'm not saying that you
know that they need to have a purpose
and that purpose needs to be somehow
authorized by the superintendent or the
school board but
you know because we have kids in the
facility we can't just let people come
walking in i understand it may be an
elected official but you know i guess it
goes back to looking at the particular
statutes and laws in individual elected
official schools
town select boards city councilors
they're not necessarily given any other
particular rights beyond anybody else
other than the right to attend a meeting
and participate in the discussion and
and vote for example sir you know
you're an elected official you have a an
employee over here i don't think that
gives you any right to perhaps look at
his employee personnel file i presume he
has a boss that that does that i know
that's not in the just with your
question about looking at facilities um
i will also say too that the last year
and a half or so since we've still been
in the midst of the pandemic pandemic
school districts have tried to
significantly limit who's coming in and
who's going out of the building just for
simple safety reasons
if i just may fall but
i'm not sure the policy of every school
i can speak for the high school in salem
rockingham county district 8.
i walk in i have a name tag i graduated
from that school i'm an elected official
for that district they
i still sign in sign out just just like
everyone else you don't just
i'm not talking about just walking in
like it's like it's a sure it's a you
know grocery store i'm just wondering
what is the concern with having
members of the school board
maybe making unannounced visits to see
really the school operating in its
regular form not uh
to make to see what's going on i was
wondering what the concern is
thank you for the question um represent
mr chair and thank you for for
clarifying i mean most i don't think
there is necessarily a problem i mean i
think school boards prop most school
boards have a policy or the building
will have a protocol where you come in
you get buzzed in you identify yourself
perhaps show an id get a name badge but
do they let you and you know i'm not
i'm asking someone hypothetically sir i
mean do they let you just come in and
walk around
i mean i
and i know it's not my place to be
asking questions of the committee i
would find that peculiar if they let
anybody just come in and start walking
around ability elected official or not
sir
well i'm referring specifically members
of the school board
right not not myself i'm not a member of
the school
any elected official school board member
i mean if if if the board wanted to do
that or i mean or the the board wanted
to pass a protocol that you know it can
do that
i think that would be fine and you know
if a board member wants to
you know like any other visitors and
looking at the sample policy we have
you know all persons other than staff
and pupils enrolled the school
who may come to to the school for any
reason during the school day are
considered visitors and must report and
sign in at the office no objection to
that
employees of the school system
are to advise the school principal or
secretary that they are in the building
a visitor
must report to the school office and
receive permission to be on school
grounds
maybe we could make some language to
amend that there persons wishing to meet
with a teacher
for the purpose of discussing a
particular problem shall do so
at a time when it does not rough normal
school program persons wishing to make
arrangements may do so by securing an
appointment with the teacher through the
office of the principal or by direct
contact with the teacher no person shall
visit a school without first reporting
in the office of the principal as to the
purpose and in place of the visit that
one sample policy we we have
we have in place
representative newman
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
would it be fair to say if you would
look at line 9 of the
of the law that says
any person denying access in violation
of this section
shall be guilty of a class b misdemeanor
would it be fair to say that that's
somewhat of a reach beyond what the kind
of relationship that school boards have
with principals and administration
peoples and officers
thank you for the question
representative yes nhsba would certainly
oppose that the language that language
of the bill as well too you know trying
to criminalize something such as that um
you know we think would be an overreach
thank you
representative welch
thank you mr chairman
this
this bill has documents in four
sentences
if that documents wasn't there
and it was just to facilitate
what the problem was that created this
bill in the first place
would you then be opposed to it i thank
you for the question representative
could i ask you to repeat the first part
of your question i missed that sir
well it says documents here
i'm familiar with the situation that
created this bill okay
and the documents were not a question to
me the individual
made a statement
the superintendent overreacted and
borrowed him from the property now how
can he do his job when he's elected
he should have access to the facility
would you not agree thank you for the
question uh representative yes if
a school board member wants to view the
property nhsba has no objection to that
um the the situation in and of itself
i'm not familiar with that you know i
would argue that you know if it was one
situation
you know one time with one school board
member and one superintendent i think
somebody mentioned the anecdotal
evidence what may not be anecdotal what
may have actually happened i don't know
if we need to change the law it sounds
like an employment issue more than
anything between the school board and
and and and the superintendent
i agree excuse me follow up
i think what what got me
fired up about this is the fact that
we're talking about all kinds of records
and employee records and everything else
that's not part of the bill i don't
think that was the intent
and it just seems that we wasted an
awful lot of time talking about all
these different things
and
i know the documents are listed in the
bill but if they weren't there shouldn't
be a problem should they
thank you for the question um
thank you for the question
representative well i mean is the intent
to
mean documents or is intended to mean
public records because those may be two
different things
a public record has a as a definition
within rsa91a has exemptions within rsa
91a
5 i believe it is so
you know a document within the
possession of a school district may not
be a public record
thank you
representative testerman
thank you thank you from taking my
question
i sit on a school board besides what i
do here
so uh
i i'm familiar with the school boards
association can you give me an idea of
the size of your budget
and what your chart what what the cost
is per
student or per school however you do it
thank you for the question
representative
mr chair is that in any way jermaine to
the bill if you want to know
representative
our operating budget is about eight
hundred thousand dollars per year our
dues vary anywhere between about a
thousand dollars for a small district in
about 7 200 hours from manchester okay
and since you raised the issue of
germaine considering that it involves
members of the budget committee
question regarding costs and expenses
i would find jermaine to the bill if a
member of the committee raised that
point of order but respect to members of
the public you're not permitted to raise
such a
point of order thank you very much sir
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you
for your testimony
who do you believe
um
can audit
the records to make sure that the
money's just not being you know that
comes up disappears
and i was just curious also if um
hanover and goffstown are members
thank you very
thank you for the question
representative
most school boards have a professional
audit done every year and if they don't
they should an audit is different than
ascertaining whether or not um you're
getting a return on investment though i
know that there are
within this body within you know this
building the um the cost of special
education and the number of um
students we have that are identified as
special education students statewide has
been a significant issue for a number of
years i don't have any idea why our
numbers are greater or higher in new
hampshire than they are in other parts
of the of the country i simply don't
know that
so in terms of an audit you know most
school boards have an audit done
done every single year um you know again
that's different than ascertaining the
roi
um goffstown is a member the hanover
dresden school district is member as
well too sir and a follow-up
representative recognized for a
follow-up thank you mr chairman um
who is doing the audit then
you know is it
are they audited themselves like police
do or is it you know your association
will out of them or i mean are they are
they
sided with one side you know are they in
support of the what they're doing and
how do you get a fair audit you know is
it a fair audit
thank you thank you very much for the
question representative there's a firm
an accounting firm here in concord
called plodzick and sanderson p-l-o-d
z-i-k
my understanding is they do the vast
majority of audits for school districts
in the state
the professional accounting auditing
firm all right thank you
representative conley thank you and
thank you for taking the question
as the bill is written
is there any document that would not be
subject to
an elected school board member or
elected budget committee member
uh in any record in any district
thanks for the question representative
if i understand the question is there is
there any document that would not be
subject to disclosure if
if i may ask for clarification
is there any limit on documents that
could be shared with the school board
member budget committee member as
contemplated under the bill yeah thank
you very much as i mentioned if we're
going to if we're going to interpret
documents as meaning public records rsa
91a colon 5 um under the right to know
law lists the exemptions to public
records saying these are there are
public records your minutes your
invoices contracts so on and so forth
and then there's a very long list of
documents that are not that are called
that are exempt from public disclosure
so you know it it's very broad-based but
the the
i mean
the quick answer is you know it says
something any any record or document
that um whose disclosure would otherwise
constitute an invasion of privacy i'm
trying to pull up the the quick language
right here if
if you give me a
if that'd be all right mr chair
um
records pertaining without it
and other files whose disclosure would
constitute an invasion of privacy so
that's pretty broad and and
there are court cases that
that have to interpret that because it's
it's so broad-based but that's the
language of the statute
thank you that that's not the language
of the bill but um well and under the
bill as the bill is written is there any
part of the school that a school board
member could not access the locker room
facilities cheerleading practice vaccine
clinic
anything at all within a school building
that this person could not access as the
bill is written um
thank you for the question
representative
i i don't believe there would be any
limitations thank you
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question
would you what did i say
oh my god
my apologies mr chairman
i juggle two committees guys
thank you for taking my question
would you
would you agree that one way
to solve the problem of documents would
be as an example we've talked a lot
about ieps
so if in a student's iep it says two
hours of counseling a week
and it's an outside counseling agency
and you are billed for those services
when you if you're the treasurer and
you're signing off on the checks and the
check is going to abc counseling
that you are able to have a copy of the
invoice you can
absolutely cross off the student's name
but you can see the service provider's
name the amount of hours
and then it is the job of the personnel
to match up that invoice with the iep
services on the services page
thank you very much for the question
representative i think i understand what
you're getting at and you know
nhsba generally takes the position that
anything dealing with money is going to
be public information or public record
anyway whether or not it's an invoice or
a bill certain things will be redacted
the student's name you know johnny jones
for the two hours of physical therapy
that's going to be redacted but the
invoice and the and the and the check
that the school district writes to pay
for that service is going to be public
public information anyway anything
dealing with money you know our default
position is if it deals with money it's
going to be public information
if the chair may inquire with a question
and thank you for taking my question and
i'll preface this by saying i'm not
suggesting that a member of the budget
committee is in a position to
be evaluating whether an iep is
appropriate for a particular student or
not they weren't involved in that
process what i'm concerned with
is if an if a certain number is given to
the budget committee or to the
school board
if they don't have access to that
the information in the iep how are they
supposed to make an informed decision
whether to
approve that figure or not
it seems that i'm just my point is it
seems like they're operating in the dark
and i have no reason to think those
numbers are being misrepresented
throughout the state it's just
if one were to inquire
about that number
they don't really have much information
to go off other than
the number thanks for the question um mr
chair i mean
you know
the iep's are a couple different i'm
trying to think of the right angle to go
with with my answer here first of all
special education is so highly regulated
by the federal government that you know
the state laws the state rules are a
little bit
broader if you will giving more rights
to students
in new hampshire than the federal law
but in terms of
whether or not you're going to pay for
it
school boards have
one option relative to special education
costs pay for it it's as simple as that
federal law dictates that these services
be provided the only school board
responsibility relative to special
education is to is to fund it and put it
in the budget and then pay for it and
that's
i'm not trying to be blunt or
or or flipping but that's the reality of
what special education is about you pay
you pay for the bill now can a school
district can a school board and choir do
um not a financial audit as we were
talked about but an audit of of staffing
in conjunction with the superintendent
do we have the right staff do we have
the proper number of staff are they
being allocated the right way is there a
way to cut this staff and add this so
perhaps you know we get better services
and drive down some of this cost
absolutely that's a conversation that
the school board should have with its
administrators if it feels that's that's
prudent relative to student concerns or
budgetary concerns but they're not going
to get that from looking at the iep
um it's not a school board's
responsibility to ensure that johnny got
his two hours of speech therapy
you know there's no school board
hearings relative to special education
it's all run through the department of
education there's a complaint process
through the department of education in
the school board's responsibility for
special education is to staff it and and
fund it
and that's the law i'm not saying that
because that's my opinion by any means
thank you and if i can ask a follow-up
to clarify your testimony are you
suggesting that the school board
is not in shouldn't be in a position to
really question the figure presented to
itself it's just whether to approve it
or not
that
thank you for the question um mr chair
no the board can certainly have those
questions during budget time but if a
child is found to be in need of services
under special education law and the iep
team through the iep process
you know requires this level of services
this number of aids this number of of
out-of-district placements or services
or whatever it may be
the iep team
parent
teacher
special ed teacher
um you know maybe a special ed director
maybe a physical therapist or a speech
therapist that team
six eight ten people are meeting and
they determine
what the services are that the child
needs
and then once that is ascertained when
they determine what the what the
services are that that that child needs
the district has an obligation to pay
for presuming that the parents in the
district agree to
those being the services that are needed
the school board does not get involved
in determining whether or not johnny
needs one hour physical therapy or two
hours of physical therapy
it's that's a it's a student matter
that's dealt with at the at the at the
building level with teachers and
specialists and the parents being active
participants in this
thank you thank you
all right
see no no hands raised i want to thank
you thank the witness for his testimony
thank you very much
if there's any members of the public
wish to testify you haven't already
seen none
we will now close uh the public hearing
on hb 1072
i just tell them remind the members
we'll be in we'll be in recess for five
till
2 55.
so
all right we're going to open we're
going to open some executive sessions
just
well we can do two i have two more
sheets
uh
well first i'm going to open the
executive session on hb
opening the executive session on ca
cr 35
my mistake thank you representative
yeah we'll go with 1400 next but we'll
start with cacr35
we've now opened the executive session
on cacr35
i thought it was
testament do you wish to be wrecked
recognize to make it a motion
is there a second
it has been seconded by representative
welch
representative testman used to speak to
your motion of any speed to legislate
i agree with mr with representative muse
that
this doesn't rise to a
constitutional amendment
and it's
we don't have other ones about
about agriculture so we don't need this
this is another cannabis bill
yes
thank you representative chessman
in respect to the now we had a few ca
cr's involving cannabis this one i think
is the most detailed at least in the
sense of if it were to be
become a constitutional amendment it
would be
it's clear what would what it would do
however
this is something that can be done
through an act of legislation
it wouldn't need to be done through a
cacr
the only difference is is whether we
think
one would become law over the other
obviously there's a different procedure
process but
i mean all adults have the right to
possess use cultivate
cannabis subject to regulations or taxes
on commercial activity
as the general court may impose so i
mean to me that
that can simply be
a legislative that can be an rsa as a
policy not a necessarily a
constitutional amendment that's just my
only observation
the policy issue aside
representative thank you mr chair uh
yeah i know i think i'd be happy to you
know legalize cannabis and i think but i
think that all the com the arguments
that were heard that we've already had
on this i think we
we can just put it like you know we can
move forward and just take a quick quick
vote on this but on my end i'm probably
going to support but
i know how the end's going to be
i'll just throw this out there if things
don't go the way i i hope
with another bill if someone were to
refile a cacr next term
this is the one i like the best out of
all three that's just my opinion that
doesn't matter
representative thank you mr chairman
after having
my
friend in front of me turn around and
ask me why
i thought about it
why i voted to itl the other bill
and he's correct that
the first cacr was itled and the second
one's itled
and then
my good friend
representative true keeps looking at me
and
i think i'm gonna oppose the itl this
time because you know we we should let
the voters at least have one of the
bills and as you point out that this is
the best of the group of them
so i guess i'm gonna
probably go with my two colleagues that
i mentioned
representative marston
representative true
thank you mr chair
um so it's been said that we don't need
to have a
constitutional amendment we could just
pass a law for this
um
but we haven't
and i don't think we're going to pass
one this year either
so this is the opportunity
to let those anecdotal voters
who say that they are in favor of
legalization
to have their voice
because they're not getting a voice
through the representatives
this year
because
legalization is not going through the
house it's not going through the senate
and it's not getting past the governor
for whatever reason
the important thing is
we're here as representatives of the
people
surveys say the people would like it to
be legalized
and this is the bill that can do it
so i will not support the ito
thank you mr chair
seeing no hands raised at this time
we'll now move the question if you're in
support of the motion of any speeding to
legislate please say
yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burke
no
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
the clerk votes no
representative testerman yeah
representative true nay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman yes
representative jack
yes representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative bolden
no
representative conley no
representative bradley
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
14 yays six nays one not voting
the motion of innings being the
legislative
passes representative chessman will you
be submitting it
i
i envision that
different different uh
vote tallies but yes will they be a
minority report that also will be very
similar
yes i'll write a minority report
thank you representative burt
at this time when i'll close the
executive session on cacr35
uh we can do that we can do 1400 or
so we're passing around amendments to
one is an amendment for hp 1400 which
we're going to do next we're also just
for the sake of
expediting the process we're passing out
an amendment for hb 13
33 so
don't be surprised if that one comes up
next
that's a different one
what's
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1400
at this time the chair recognized
representative roy
um
i'm going to make a motion of an
expedient to legislate on hp 1400
that has been seconded by representative
marston
representative roy you wish to speak to
your
motion of innings being to legislate i
do um
um while i'm sure all of us including
myself are getting a little tired of
talking about marijuana
um
this this proposed statute
is um
looking for a problem that's already
been solved
the supreme court has ruled that
it's not
probable cause the center of marijuana
is not probable cause
possession of marijuana is not a crime
so the scent of marijuana
can't be probable cause
for a search
because it's not evidence of a crime so
i don't see the need to codify this and
clutter up our criminal statutes
with a a bill that's already it's
already law it's it's it's redundant
based on decisions of the court
um so it really it's just it would be
putting something in statute just for
the sake of putting something in statute
in my opinion
and that's why i would support an itl of
this
representative bolden
as was discussed in
the public hearing on this bill
a supreme court decision is not the same
thing as law
each individual police department has to
be aware of the decision
in order to
follow it
and just as a point of clarification i
believe representative roy said that
possession of marijuana is not a crime
it is in some cases depending on the
quantity
and that is the issue at hand
is that
an odor
may or may not be evidence
of a crime and that's the problem that's
created in using an odor as
probable cause
if there were
something
that would make a person easily or a
vehicle or space easily smell like
alcohol and let's say
it involves a vehicle that's being
driven there would be an issue of
do we smell alcohol because someone's
drunk or do we smell alcohol for a
different reason
and it is the case that
uh
a lot of natural things like skunks
and different types of perfumes can
smell like
marijuana
i included
as a handout the
supreme court
decision that's being referenced
it is
necessary for the legislature to codify
things like this if we agree with them
or to codify in the opposite if we feel
that the supreme court arrived at
a conclusion that we don't support
we don't just let the supreme court make
law
we have the right to
undermine their choices if we like as
the legislature so let's say we didn't
agree with this decision that would
require legislation so if we agree with
it it also requires legislation
we've had we've ridden
and passed laws in this
body that were
deemed unconstitutional and they needed
to be repealed by this body after the
fact
so it's an opinion but it's just an
opinion and we do need the law it's not
clutter
it's the supreme court decision that
really is clutter
because in the sense that clutter is
confusing and messy
if there's police departments or
individual officers who aren't aware of
this decision
then
we're going to have different outcomes
that depend entirely upon the knowledge
of the persons involved and not on what
the law is
and i just want to mention
as is obvious to everyone
there is an amendment that deals with
the concerns about the um
language that were brought up in the
hearing
representative you may state your point
of order
in respect to the point of order the
question that's before the committee is
is not the amendment it is
inexpensive i wasn't discussing the
amendment i was saying that it exists
let me
i could just finish
uh
so try it i have every right to say that
it exists
i i do have every right to say that it
exists daryl the member will suspend i
understand how the people the member
will suspend
and it's so inappropriate for you to cut
people off out of order this is supposed
to be a deliberative body order
rational conversation
if you're let me just i have to rule on
the point of order now i understand you
don't want to wait for that ruling and
perhaps that ruling may be even in
favorable to what you're saying
but you won't actually let the chair
finish and it make a said vote
you're not a judge you don't rule on
points of order this is you're a
legislator
your time to speak but just so you know
you don't rule on anything because
you're not a judge i just want to pass
out would you like to challenge the
ruling the chair you're free to no i'm
just letting you know that your language
isn't the member will suspend ask me a
question you are free to challenge the
ruling of the chair
if you would allow the chair to make
said ruling which you may or may not
even agree with
so if you want to talk stop asking me
questions
so
i'm going to rule the member out of
order
because you're continuing to speak
without being recognized to speak
and
i'm asking that any testimony or excuse
me any comments be limited to the
underlying bill because the question
before the committee
is in expedition to legislate
so i would i'm going to allow you to
continue to speak but please try to
limit your comments to the underlying
bill not the amendment all i had to say
the end of my testimony
not testimony but my comments on the
bill was
there's an amendment that was the end of
my sentence but instead we've had this
protracted routine
because there's some kind of gotcha
attitude in this committee that doesn't
need to exist
that was literally all i had to say the
member will suspend please honest you're
not permitted to assign motives to other
members i'm not assigning motive to
members based on legislation
i'm ruling you out of order and you're
not recognized to speak if you continue
to speak
you're not speaking well recognized so
you're just speaking out of order
disrupting the committee
do any other members wish to speak
representative roy
thank you mr chairman um
back to the the matter at hand
with regard to supreme court decisions
being law that they actually they
actually are um unfortunately i agree
that we um
but we we have a long history arizona
versus um versus the miranda
terry v ohio all these things are are
not codified yet they are followed by
the police
miranda warnings are required when
someone's in consolidated interrogation
we've heard testimony about that
numerous times in this committee so the
police departments will be well aware of
the court decision
i don't think there are any police
departments in the state of new
hampshire that are not aware of the
decision from two years ago that said
they cannot search cars based on the
smell of marijuana anymore
so again i go back i don't feel that
this is necessary based on the fact that
it's already
the law of the land vis-a-vis the
decision of the supreme court of the
state of new hampshire thank you
representative kessman
i talked with some police and
their their only point was
you can't use marijuana
and i think that's what this one said
as the only reason for getting a search
warrant
it has to be used
as a
contributing factor or whatever you want
to call it you know there's something
else you see in the car or something
so
and that's the only thing my problem
with this bill is that it makes it an
only reason
and that isn't
you know what we ought to be doing
at this time we now move the question
if you in support of the motion of the
index being to legislate please say
yay if you're opposed
please say nay that the clerk will now
call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burt
yes representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative testament
yeah
representative true
yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman
no
representative jack yes
representative bourdain no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative bolden
no
representative conley no
representative bradley
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
12 yays eight nays one not voting
the motion passes by is it twelve
twelve eight
five twelve yeah eight nays the motion
passes
will there be a majority report
will you see would there be amanda says
she would do the minority
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on hb 1400
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on house bill 1333
as relative to previous convictions for
driving while intoxicated
this time the chair recognizes
representative welch to
make a motion
thank you mr chairman i move that we
amend house bill 1333 fn
with amendment 08138
so just to clarify representative welch
you're making a motion of ought to pass
and you wish to offer an amendment
and is there a second to that
seconded by representative boardney
and
representative welch if i speaking
correctly
there was
a drafting error in the bill and this
the amendment's
correcting that drafting error is that
that is correct
it's the same error that we had once
before
thanks for pointing that out
this time we'll now
move the question if you're in support
of adopting amendment 2022-0813h
please say yay if you're opposed please
say nay the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes yes
representative welch yes representative
burke
yes
representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative testament
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman yes
representative jack yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman yes
representative bolden
representative conley
yes
representative bradley
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas the chair votes yes
18 yays one nay two not voting
the motion passes the amendment's
adopted representative what you wish to
be recognized for a motion of ought to
pass as amended
i beg that motion yes
is there a second
that has been seconded by representative
martin
you know what can i change my i'm sorry
this was the amendment
i meant yes
i apologize
i don't
that's a motion for reconsideration but
we could just
go through all that we would technically
have to never mind forget it leave it i
i will say it would not change the
outcome and
it doesn't matter
it's it's like the vote right
never mind forget it
brian you're brave soul representative
harry karate you could make it up by
voting in favor of the art that passes
amended
i mean it was a unanimous vote right
it's thrown out there
representative welch you wish to speak
to your motion
no
well
i think i
i will say i summed up the intent of the
bill with
with my my testimony again it's just to
clarify it's only applying to third and
fourth offenses
and the idea is
in order to convict someone of a
subsequent defense they have to actually
be convicted of the first offense so if
someone were to get arrested three times
for drunk driving in a two-month time
period
you're unlikely to have a conviction on
those so they're gonna be charged with
several first offenses so
i think extending it for the look back
period for third and fourth offenses to
20 years
we're really focusing on habitual
offenders at this point so
i think it's a modest way to address
what i would say
repeat offenses that put public safety
in danger
so i hope you all join me in supporting
octopass
and did pass this committee last term
seeing no uh hands raised will not move
the question if you're in support of the
motion of octopass has amended please
say yay
if you're opposed please say nay the
clerk will not call the rule
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt yes
representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative testerman
yes
representative true
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
yes
representative jack yes representative
bourdain yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative bolden
representative conley
yes representative bradley
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
to 0.
move for consent
so moved no objections
representative welts i i will do the
honors of the majority report i wrote
one last year
it's there it's published
i'll have to track it down but i'm sure
i can
repurpose that
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on house bill 13
33.
so who did the other passes amended was
that the same welch and board name
wallace
okay
thank you
so
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on hb
1085 that's relative to ignition lock
requirements
hello
at this time uh the chair recognized uh
representative roy to make a motion
i would like to move hp 1085 as ought to
pass
is there a second
i apologize
uh represent representative muse you're
recognized
sorry you've seconded the most about the
past
do you wish to speak to the motion
i would defer to the chair to explain to
the committee his thoughts on that
representative since you seconded would
you wish to
address it
you may reserve
for later on the discussion if you'd
like
i do think that we heard testimony that
that this particular bill does address a
significant loophole
in our law now i think the last thing
that any of us want is
to provide loopholes for drunk drivers
to get back on the road so
this bill would go a long way towards uh
towards closing that loophole and
suggest we pass it
representative music
the term loophole is what came to my
mind as well when i saw this and
i heard a lot of discussion about
you know any vehicles register that
person whether that's the economic side
of that
i certainly appreciate that but the goal
of the interlocking device
is to prevent the person from operating
a motor vehicle without
blowing into the machine
at all cost if the person were to
violate this law that in and of itself
the system has already failed even if
that person
wasn't even intoxicated or impaired
so
i don't think it's unreasonable to make
a presumption that if a vehicle is
registered in that person's name that
they tend to drive that vehicle
and then
having to demonstrate on a regular basis
i'm not sure if there's
courts have interpreted that but if
they're offering a motor vehicle
and they have not blown into the
ignition interlock device
they're basically
walking around the system and taking
advantage of and exploiting it
when they've either a have been arrested
several arrested and convicted several
times or been involved in aggravated
offense
so
i think this really
captures the intent of what the bill
the law should have been from the start
so i would i would support not to pass
representative boardney
thank you sure
i'm going to oppose the ultra pass
i really don't like this bill because it
requires all vehicles that basically are
registered by
the individual to have interlock device
on them not only does that
punish
the uh
person but also furnishes anybody that's
driving those vehicles in within the
family
um
i think that the original language
takes care of what we wanted to do we
would really prefer that
well this person is under this uh
order that
anytime he drives
rv
they have to drive a vehicle with an
interlock device
and that is not clearly stated in this
this means that any vehicle he uses or
has registered to his
name
has to have an interlock device
and
now
we are not necessarily agreed that the
vehicles in this case are just
exclusively automobiles it could be also
as
mentioned earlier
motorcycles
snowball bills and possibly even boats
and we do did learn from
the lobbyists that such devices are
available for all those vehicles so
it's unclear if they really want to
limit this to
automotive our vehicles for the road
that that was not stated
so this is we're talking about a
thousand dollars
a year for each vehicle
so i'm gonna
remain opposed
thank you
and i just would say representative
ordinate the existing law is that any
vehicle registered to that person
already would have require
the interlocking device so that's the
existing law what this is changing is
it's it's or used by that person on a
regular basis so the right it's just
striking the regular basis so strictly
they're using a vehicle
and
the point of that interlocking device if
they're using a vehicle is to
well have to use the interlocking device
so it should apply to any vehicle so
when i re-redirect you yes
but that striking those three words
means that
vehicles that
uh the
perpetrator has
in his household but never uses has to
be uh
interlocked
so
that does put a different emphasis
instead of
uh being the vehicles that the
person uses
on a regular basis basis
which would probably want they want to
mean any vehicle that they're likely to
use should have interlock device
means all vehicles in that household
have to be have intellectual advice that
means if their spouse is going to be
driving a vehicle they are also subject
to
the inconvenience of the interlock
device while they are operating that
vehicle
unless they register to themselves
my my interpretation is that if if the
vehicle's not registered in there in
that person's name it's wretched in
their spouse's name or partner's name or
whatever whatever then in that scenario
it wouldn't require an interlocking
device now if they were to use their
spouse's car
that's that's different
they would
that would be problematic and it's up to
that's the decision they would be making
on whether they want to put one in both
vehicles is just one of them
you may respond
uh i don't know about your household but
in my household all our vehicles are
registered by both myself and my spouse
so uh
i think that that's
the case for most households
well
i understand i understand the concern
you're raising i will just say that that
is a problem the existing law
i disagree it's not an existing law it
is it is
we'll just we're going to go on this one
representative wallace and
thank you for uh recognizing mr chairman
just another
to carry on with your discussion um as
somebody who has
many years experience installing and
calibrating these devices
um
this bill is a designed to address a
loophole
i've had many clients that would drive
their motorcycle because from a
liability perspective i would never
install a breathalyzer interlock because
it does require an additional blow
randomly and frequently as you're
driving on the road and that's not very
safety minded on a motorcycle
another
item addressed in this bill is the dmv
will mark the driver's license in some
manner for these people so that um
if they go to register excuse me rent a
motor vehicle you're going to have to
produce your driver's license
there may not have access to your
driving record but with that mark of the
beast on your license they're not going
to rent you an automobile because it
doesn't have that interlock device
thereby preventing that work around of
the system that we've got in place to
prevent
these individuals from operating on the
road under while they're impaired uh
just another couple of thoughts
representative harry gathered thank you
so are you
can i just ask him a question what he
just said so you're saying that these
people have something on their license
no there's a provision in the bill that
the dmv will mark their driver's license
and put a decal on their registration
plate so it's blatantly obvious to the
motoring public and to people that may
look at their driver's license that they
have a requirement for
um
this interlock device so you know if
they're exhibiting lane control issues
maybe they're trying to operate this uh
the interlock while they're driving down
the road
and maybe some would drop a dime if
they're having problems
okay so i i too thought this was a good
bill
but
i'm gonna say last year whenever we had
this before i probably never read it
through
but today in reading through it that
part of the build that states you know
that
any any and every car that you own would
have to be um you would have to have
that device on it um
i thought this was a good way to clean
that up
and that was my recommendation to the
representative
however um
after she left she did send us an email
a few of us are emailed
and she chose not to do
to put in you know to clean up the bill
so that it would be
pallable to the entire team
so um with that said i don't think i can
um
vote
in favor of this bill
because i don't really believe that
anyone i don't care how many vehicles
you have and what they said was that
the um motorcycle anything that's
drivable is supposed to have a lot
that's what
these one of these people said
okay so let's say you have 10 vehicles
or whatever in some or
motor vehicle whatever you want to call
them anything that you can drive
you would have to pay
150 or whatever whatever the cost is for
every last one of those vehicles i don't
i'm sorry i just think that's
unreasonable yes and did
you maybe mr
represe i think this went to
transportation committee last year not
to us
uh representing okay i thought it came
to us and i must have read didn't read
at all or something
but i took this says
even though i like what they wanted to
do with the bill i still felt it was an
opportunity to clean up the bill and i
feel that was rejected
well just from the technical aspects of
it if you're a multiple vehicle owner
there are multiple units
that are installed into the vehicles but
there's only one breathalyzer
okay this
they might have a spare but that handset
is the breathalyzer unit itself and it
communicates with the interlock in the
car so where they can only operate one
vehicle at a time or maybe there's a
spouse they may have an additional
handset so it's not a complete
1500 install in each vehicle
okay they might have that interlock the
the component that disables the start
circuit okay and you don't leave the
breathalyzer in the vehicle because it's
temperature sensitive you keep that in
your home with you and you bring it out
in the morning and plug it into the car
you blow through it you get a clean
sample it allows you to start the
vehicle
so
it's
one more question then you said it was
but even with that that's even worse
well just like financing an automobile
you can do it different ways you can
lease it you can buy it outright or you
can buy it you can put some money down
we did it all a myriad of ways most
people just paid a monthly lease rate um
but there was an advantage paying it off
up front so
representative newman
ray newman all right i agree
i agree with representative boarding
especially when he brought up the point
about vehicles that are registered to
both spouses
and if you read just the wording of the
bill
if i can find it here that
they shall be required by the court
after a period
as defined in rsa 259 43 in any vehicle
registered to that person
or used by that person
and then they removed what used to be
the out that would confine it to
wouldn't require it to go on more than
one vehicle
uh and it goes on from there
and so i think that what you have just
because the wording is the way the
wording is
is that if you take out the exception
and that's what we want to do
then for
vehicles that are registered to two
different people and if that's all the
vehicles in the house this would require
a
require that you install one in each one
that is registered to that person
because we've removed the exception so i
think that's the first point and the
second point is even if it's not a now
i'm confused about whether it's a
breathalyzer or whether it's a unit in
the car
you would have to buy at least you would
have to install in my reading of the
words at least whatever component is a
breathalyzer whatever that means or
whatever interlocking device whatever
that is you would have to install it in
three cars
where you had
two spouses registered to the vehicle
representative soon
yeah um
representative gathright and the other
representative newman covered most of my
thoughts but i'm stuck on
on line 23 where it says in any vehicle
registered to that person or
used by that person so is this an
it doesn't say either or it
so i i didn't know if that was some way
that somebody had two cars
registered or three whatever they could
say no this is the car i use on a
regular basis so i only need to install
the complete gizmo on this one but not
those
so
what i can what i this is my
interpretation and this is the existing
law that take this bill even if we don't
pass it
any vehicle that is registered to the
individual's name if they're required to
get
the interlocking
device in their vehicle any vehicle
registered to them period would whether
it's their name their name and their
spouse's name
would require their the interlocking
device to be installed in the vehicle
it also would be required to be
installed in vehicles not registered in
their name
that they operate on a regular basis the
issue is
operate on a regular basis what does
that mean how frequent would one have to
use a vehicle for it to then be
considered
on a regular basis
and what i understood the testimony to
be from the
representative who
sponsored the bill and introduced it was
that on the regular basis the intent is
anytime this individual's operating any
vehicle whether it's registered their
name or not
is to take the
uh to take the breath test and to use
the interlocking device so
existing law that's already the case
what this is just doing is clarifying
that it you don't have to
establish on a regular basis
so if i were to use if i'm required by
the court to use the interlocking device
and
you lend me your vehicle i although it's
a nice gesture uh
if the
interlocking device is not installed in
there i would not be permitted to
operate it
if this were to pass if i only use it
one time
you wouldn't need to
you wouldn't need to do it under the
current law but the problem with that is
i'm getting around the requirement that
the court made that i
use that interlocking device and and
just to clarify what representative
wallace just said
i i don't i don't think i heard this
morning maybe i don't remember but this
is the first time i'm hearing that if
you got three cars you could get three
sets of things but only one would be the
full
the full one that
you would be expected to use or do you
move it from one to another yes
the systems i don't know if you remember
back you know 20 years ago when we
actually installed security systems in
the cars when they didn't come factory
equipped you'd have something that would
prevent the car from being started
that's the only part that remains in the
car the little handset regardless of the
manufacturer is on a little coiled cord
and that remains with the individual
because that's what's very expensive and
it has a proprietary technology in it
and is required to be calibrated on a
monthly basis that goes into the office
with the people it goes in their home so
they can just move that from car to car
and that contains all the data that what
we call the handset
okay if but you could only operate one
vehicle at a time so if you've got
multiple drivers you would probably in
reality need at least two complete
systems so that in the event that one
vehicle is out of the driveway you still
got a handset to run that other vehicle
because unless you're trained you're not
gonna be able to get it started
thank you representative jack uh thank
you mr chairman uh the chairman did a
great job of pointing out that line five
is is verbatim in existing law
and it says because of the word or at
the end that any vehicle registered to
that person
has to have the interlock device that's
existing loss so voting against this
bill to
circumvent that isn't going to solve
your problem
there does seem to be there has been a
lot of sense in the committee today that
that requirement isn't a good idea
but but
this bill is this bill
well unamended this bill is not voting
against this bill is not solving your
issue
let me suggest a couple of ways you
could proceed you could hold the bill
and do an amendment the department of
safety was a little leery about agreeing
to that amendment
in real time
so if you were to hold the bill if you
had another executive session you could
hold the bill and amend it it does seem
that the that the committee is very
interested in deleting that requirement
uh
you could file a bill next year to
delete the requirement you could try to
get the senate to amend it
but voting against this bill today as it
sits does not
help with with the the concern that a
lot of the committee has about that
language
about any vehicle registered to
representative espitia yeah i i agree
with uh with the statement of uh
representative jack i think you know
while
sure there are there are some issues
with the existing law i don't think this
bill is meant to address those issues
this bill is too meant to address the
loophole
um that is currently that you know
that is something that you know i think
a lot of us can try to get behind um
so i think you know i want to support
this bill
um let's move forward
representative
true thank you mr chair well
most of it's already been said but i'll
say it again because
i like hanging out here
i hear the argument that
any vehicle registered to that person is
is already part of
the the law well so is on a regular
basis already part of the law
um
in three and three places on this bill
the law as it's now written says
that you must
spend all this money on any vehicle
registered to that person
that seems
very uh
a strong too strong a punishment
financially
for somebody who's done wrong
and and that can be easily corrected
if we uh
stall long enough
uh to another day so that
an amendment dropping that any vehicle
registered to that person and dropping
the on a regular basis will certainly
get my support
because
forcing somebody to register for cars
because they're registered under his net
for do the interlock
on four cars because they happen to be
registered under his name
is not going to stop him from borrowing
daryl's car tomorrow
it's not going to stop him from
borrowing anyone's car
that doesn't have the interlock that
that's that's on to the that's on the
person the person know that knows they
messed up and they have to follow the
court orders
but forcing somebody
to uh put this interlock on any vehicle
registered to that person
when that doesn't that doesn't serve any
purpose at all
is why i can't support
the otp and i would hope that
it doesn't go through today
so that uh perhaps
removing any vehicle registered to that
person
and removing on a regular basis will do
exactly what this bill
has presented meant to do
thank you mr chair
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
i will not be long-winded
i will be voting to itl and not approve
the motion that ought to pass i will be
voting against
representative burke
thank you mr chairman um
i think if scott could answer i'm
assuming it would be him to answer this
question because i just want to
understand
is it current law
right now
or is it proposed law
i have a 53 farm all super c tractor
a car and a truck that i
drive
then my wife has a car
that
i will drive once a week when i go fill
it up with gas
and occasionally other times but most of
the time i drive the other cars you know
so would i have to install them in all
four vehicles and if the answer is yes
let's say if i was the dwi person which
i don't drink
but if i did and
would i have to you know would it be
installed in all four vehicles and how
would my wife be able to drive her car
to work if there's one of those devices
in her car because i do occasionally
drive it so i'm just curious how this is
works
thank you
okay um
there wouldn't be a need to put it on
your tractor unless it's registered and
driven on the road
okay
well that's interesting
um
um it certainly is technically pause
possible as far as operating the vehicle
with the interlock
she would have to operate that and it's
quite a task
if you've ever had a pulmonary function
test or
deep breathing exercises this is not
something you just kind of breathe into
you've got to breathe from the from your
your bottom of your soul
for and hold it
and uh you know it's not the easiest
thing to do so but that's how she would
have to operate it
yep no half press it'll fail
well what would happen is could you get
around that device yes you could but it
would also set a um uh a demerit into
your unit it would be a you would be
locked out it would detect that it had
been bypassed and that would uh be a
violation on your part and it would go
on your record you'd have to answer to
it with the dmv
and representative burke in respect
under the current law if you were to
be a great husband and
take your wife's vehicle to get filled
up fill up the tank top it off once a
week i would consider that to be
operating the vehicle on a regular basis
that's not even considering the random
times you may just randomly drive it but
so under the current law you would have
to register
or
have the interlocking device installed
into all the vehicles i will say the
easiest way for an individual to avoid
this
hardship is to not
commit multiple drunk driving offenses
get
drink be double the legal limit and get
arrested for drunk driving
or being involved in an accident while
impaired from drinking alcohol so this
although i i do sympathize with the the
i guess the uh
some of the restraints this may put on
an individual this is a very
sim easy situation to
avoid
in in my opinion so just throwing it out
there representative welch
thank you mr chairman i really can't
believe we're having this discussion
over somebody who drives a car
drunk
does anybody here know anyone who has
lost a family member or a friend from a
drunk driver
i don't care what kind of a cost we put
on a drunk driver i don't want him on
the road
yep ends up sorry
and thank you for that moment of clarity
representative welch
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
i've heard a lot of talk about you know
um the person's gonna have to do this
and we have to do that and
let's get back the piggybacking off what
what the chair said um driving's a
privilege it's not a right you have a
right to drive you're a privilege to
drive
no one's forcing you to install anything
you just don't drive if you want to
drive
after having been convicted multiple
times or having been convicted double
the legal limit you say you know what
i'm going to go ahead and enter this
agreement with you state of new
hampshire so that you let me drive
then you are going to have to live up to
your side of the bargain and it may be
costly indeed um and having administered
numerous breathalyzers tests i can tell
you that the representative is correct
you do have to
blow into that thing for like 30 seconds
so
there's a cost to be paid but remember
we're not making anybody do anything
for the privilege of driving in this
state
that they
first of all violated the first
agreement where they said they wouldn't
drink and drive then they did it again
and then they did it again
the state's still willing to let them
have an opportunity to drive but now
it's going to be very very difficult and
if that's a burden on their family they
put that burden on their family not the
state of new hampshire so
as far as i'm concerned i think that
this this is a good bill and we should
pass it and not leave any loopholes
representative muse
a lot of times in this committee we're
we're forced to make hard choices
between
uh victims and offenders
and to me this is an easy choice
what we're doing is we're passing a bill
that will result in the creation of
fewer victims
so i
again i would urge us to pass this bill
representative ray newman
i don't want anybody to think that my
motivation is to
harm victims in any way i fully agree
with removing the
the
stupid ringer on my phone
i can't say anything because i
violated that rule about 20 minutes ago
thank you
i appreciate being in the same boat with
you
but i but the thing i am concerned about
is i think it's that that one sentence
is poorly written i think it could be
simply fixed
by saying someone who has a requirement
to have an interlock device when they
drive shall not drive a car without an
interlock device
and
unless there's some kind of
administrative thing that causes them to
have to have something installed
that that would solve the problem take
out the one
take out the the loophole and just say
if you are required to have an intel
have an interlock device
you shall be guilty of x when you drive
a car without an interlock device and
that would allow
people not have to get caught up in what
i think is catch-22 where the whole we
have to do a whole bunch of vehicles
i i appreciate that but my point is if
you if i
put the interlocking device into one
vehicle and say why don't it's
registered my name but i don't drive
that one we'll just leave it in my
garage
i i think it's i think i don't think
this it's out of line to have a policy
to presume you drive the car registered
your name so
in that case again if you get caught
violating this law and no one was
injured
you know that's that's the best case
scenario but the system
has already failed because the idea is
for you not to be driving without
using the interlocking device in the
first place and not only are you there's
literally a tool in their possession on
their property
that will allow them to get around this
rule and the only way they're going to
get caught would be if they were to get
be pulled over
so i just my thought is
i appreciate what you're saying because
but the idea is we don't want that
person driving period without exception
without
the interlocking device being
administered
so
that's the concern i have but i
i think we can move the question
you may you may ask a question to
representative wallace and you may
answer the question
of answering them anyway
so
the the brevarizer is the mouthpiece
have to be calibrated to the person
um no it's actually calibrated to a
laboratory standard on a monthly basis
um we use
a uh
it looks like something in the you know
in a physics lab this it's it's all
right it's calibrated
because
point out one more thing
yes you're so recognized thank you um
is there a
who is going to enforce this wall
because if it requires
interlock devices in all vehicles are
they are we going to have an enforcement
uh
agencies yes doing this the service
providers we do that
okay you're going to go to the household
and inspect all vehicles no they have to
bring their vehicles in on a monthly
basis to have and we look at to make
sure that the the connection points to
the vehicle's wiring harness are not
tampered with
we calibrate the machines because the
evidence that the breath samples that
that device takes
are
prima facie evidence can be used in a
court and they can convict you as a
with of an oui from the data dump from
that device that's why we calibrate it
monthly
to a laboratory standard not to the
individual
right this time we'll now move when i'll
move the question
if you in support of the motion of ought
to pass
please say
yay
if you are opposed please say nay the
clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
absolutely
representative burt
no
representative rhodes yes representative
greene
go on
clerk votes yes representative testament
yes
representative true
nay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
no
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman yes
representative jack yes
representative boardney
no
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley
another one
representative bradley
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes 11 yays six nays
and a handful not voting
by uh
the most about to pass
passes will there be a minority report
minority report
will it be a majority report
and i made them
whoever uh
just to point out
this was hb 1465 last year i bet there's
a very good uh majority report
already written floating around up there
1465 was the same bill last term
from that's what uh i have my notes from
the
as soon as possible but noon noon time
tomorrow
so this time we'll now close the
executive session on hb
1085.
we will not be executing anything else
today just one
just one
bill that was
hb 349.
was a bill that we passed in the house
last
last year
it was i don't know the proper term but
it was
their version of retained in the other
body
re-refer i think they what they use
anyway they there was a senate they
amended that bill all they amended was
the effective date
and that was the bill
that would if you were driving with a
suspended license
it would allow you to you to take in
consideration out-of-state convictions
that were
of similar in nature so i was going to
make a motion to concur with the senate
amendment it just simply changed the
effective date
anyone have any questions on that bill
you for telling us
see
it's it's hb 349. we passed in the house
last year
uh it would it
it was
i think the term is re-referred but it
was the the senate version of retaining
a bill
it was retained in committee the the
amendment all it does is change the
effective date it doesn't change any of
the actual subject matter of the bill
uh
so i'm i was going to make a
recommend a motion to concur with the
senate amendment on hb349
and does anyone have any questions on
that
that is the only change
if i recall i i want to i'm going off
memory i think it was 14 to 7 in this
committee i
i believe it's a voice vote in the
i don't i don't remember of the problem
i would have to check
i would have to check but did
at this time the the committee the
criminal justice committee will now be
adjourned
so just while i have everyone here
uh the deadline we have for bills is
you